I try,
I,
I'll,
I won't take them unless I can actually
sell it,
but having to sell it more than once,
which doesn't happen.
Which you have squarespace now.
I think we're live right?
We're live.
All right.
I like that one because it's real,
like there's no disputing.
It's a really good product like.
Yeah,
but Charlie does my website and uses
squarespace so he can actually tell the
shit that it does.
Well,
red bands made like no bullshit,
like a dozen or more websites during the
time in which it took to do a
squarespace commercial.
He would just slap together a bunch of
pictures,
call it red blood easy and put it up
online in like 30 seconds and I'm not
bullshitting.
It's that easy.
But yeah,
we made.
What was the one that he made some gay
one with Ari.
Do you remember?
Jamie burt?
Squirts was one of them,
but there was something about Ari's legs
or something,
something sexually feet on the table or
some shit like that.
Yeah,
something like that.
Right.
Okay.
So it's probably not,
it doesn't exist anymore.
Maybe some fan picked it up in Omaha,
but um,
it's,
it's a legit sponsor,
right?
You can't argue with it.
Some of them to get sketchy.
There's a couple light turn down some
luxurious sheets and I have no idea what
it was,
but I do buy nice sheets because I sleep
a lot.
So they go,
they're going to send you a free set of
these luxurious sheets and these are
$300 sheets that are shittier than the
$59 ones I bought from some triple a
promotion on a email spam blast.
I'm not promoting that.
Money's not that good.
But we had this one called lumosity.
Have you heard of that one?
And it's like brain games and they're
actually kind of cool.
They're fun to play,
they're stimulating,
but I'm like,
games are good for you.
Like if you play chess,
chess is good for the brain.
It's good for the brand.
Try to solve puzzles,
try to.
It's like an exercise.
So that's undeniable.
But I guess someone had fucked up and
like made some outlandish claims.
Like it helps early onset Alzheimer's
disease and memory loss.
And a lot of like,
I don't know who said what,
I don't know what happened,
but they lost millions of dollars in
court so they must have said some stupid
shit.
They were one of our sponsors and while
we were doing it,
people will like one of my sponsors and
that really went sideways.
You got in late,
you're late adapter.
Yeah.
There were just.
It's not a bad product.
It's good.
They're fun.
It's fun to play.
They're stimulating little games,
but I guess they don't know.
Make you smarter or fix your problem is
I would promote shit.
This is not my sponsor just because I
liked it because I had to go to break.
So just make up a fucking neck stuff you
like or stuff I didn't even.
I would just pick random things out of.
All right.
Let's say a Bangor Maine,
a wedding attire and this google
someone's shop and then do a whole like
really dumb.
Hey,
you're getting married on Tuesday.
Wow.
Where is your wife going to get a
wedding dress on short notice.
Just and do the actual company without
their knowledge or consent.
And just do a really bad commercial just
for fun.
That's a good move.
That's a real good move.
Yeah.
But things that I actually liked,
I've bet on a bed online dot age.
That's where I do my sports betting and
then we.
But I promote them all the time,
like how am I going to get a deal of
them promote free.
Anyway,
I keep telling you that what'll happen
is that's Brian Hennigan,
my filthy uncut,
scotsmen manager sitting in who tells me
don't say anything for free.
Brian.
That's a good.
That's always a good move.
Don't say nothing for free,
Dude.
You're a.
you're off often on his podcast.
Very enjoyable.
Well listen you guys together.
Oh,
podcasts.
Pretty bad ass.
I enjoy it.
It's so loose.
So one of my favorite because it like,
it has no beginning.
It's just the conversations in mid
stride.
When is it on?
I don't know if it's fucking on this.
Things moving.
Okay.
It's my open mic.
I don't have comedy there.
So I do a podcast as open mic.
Just to keep in the mode of talking in
an entertainment arena.
And you cross training?
Yes,
basically it is,
right?
I mean it kind of in a way a defacto
open mic where otherwise I'd just be
watching fucking Netflix all the time so
I have to at least do something
artistically creatively.
Fuck.
We haven't put out a podcast.
We need to a week we try to hit.
How many people do we have?
Just over 5,000.
Do you guys,
do you think that it's possible that you
could sustain a small comedy club,
a small local comedy club?
Like we were kind of talking about this
the other night at the comedy store.
Like I think if you put together like a
small comedy clubs like you know,
150 seats or so like you could fill that
even though it's a weird place,
it's in the middle of nowhere.
You could make it like a destination
thing.
Like guys like me would do it.
I would do it for sure.
Problem is the.
And I make jokes about it,
but the main source of income and
[inaudible] his permanent disability or
handyman really.
So no one charges when I just,
I,
I've filmed as my last special there and
the fact that I was charging money at
all was reprehensible to a lot of the,
the town really.
Fortunately it sold out with out of
towners within under an hour.
Probably a better move that way,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of people in a small town,
they like.
I'm a rich guy there and again,
it's a destination at the weekend,
meaning it's the same as every comedy
club on the planet.
It only makes money at the weekends.
It could.
And it could do.
You could do that because you're only
like how far from Tucson?
An hour and a half.
Yeah.
See,
that's not much actual Tucson,
but that's driving.
That's a fun track.
Like that'd be a fun track.
You know,
you fly into Tucson,
fuck yeah.
We're going to go to the fucking standup
comedy club and then you take a drive,
you rent a car.
Uber if you're baller,
these stay at this shady Dell Dot com
place.
But know that that's a friend of mine,
that vintage trailer park.
It's.
I look for reasons to stay there.
Hey,
let's fumigate the house so we have a
reason to stay at the Shady Dell.
Nineteen fifties airstream trailers,
the silver gun,
everything inside old records with old
record players,
silverware and cups or wow,
19 Tiki bus.
Wow.
You could just go back and dig and
roleplay and got married there on a.
They have a 38 foot yacht that you can
stay on.
Just land locked and unlocked.
Dry,
dry.
Dr. Look how well that marriage went.
Hey,
citizen,
I don't want to insinuate to any crime
took place on this podcast.
Let's change the subject rapidly.
That's fucking.
How ridiculous is that that all you have
to do to become a citizen is you got to
get a person in that country to sign
some paper saying you guys are together
like you.
We'll let you.
We'll let you in.
Would you gotta you gotta be in love.
I don't know.
This is real.
The fact that they'll fucking
investigate like I don't believe it.
I would gay marry someone to get them in
the country just for the 10 minutes of
material.
We were going to gain,
marry each other on the last episode of
the just to save each other's money
before it was officially canceled.
I remember I was in the Atlanta
punchline parking lot drunk and I called
Zoe Friedman.
I go,
I know this show is going to get
canceled,
but please.
It was just when Massachusetts legalized
gay marriage was New Hampshire was.
It was,
it was new.
It was big news and I go and we just met
her last episode,
be me and Joe getting gay married and
then show how perfect a marriage that
would be.
We don't fight over the remote control.
You want to go bowling?
I want to go fishing.
There's no problem.
Yeah,
we,
we explain how awesome the gay lifestyle
really would be other than the gay
parts.
Yeah.
Other than all the bud fucking Dick
Soccer
seems like a great time.
What do you do that before you get
married?
Just get it out of the way.
Every fucking Sitcom with a married
Hetero couple is uh,
uh.
Well,
you want to fuck.
Oh fuck.
Well,
what's fascinating to me is the
reinvigoration of manhood that I
witnessed and men that are in their
forties,
they get divorced like p segway talking
to live again,
you know,
don't you notice that the saddest part
is it's men or women,
but I noticed the women who just,
they kids when they were 18 and they
married some fucking dentist and now
they're pushing 40 and the kids in
college and they get divorced and
they're going to go out on the town and
we're going to have fun tonight and they
just stand out like they're trying to
dance when no one else is dancing on the
dance floor.
And yeah,
it's sad.
It's odd.
We go right back to,
you know,
when they graduated college,
but now they're 41.
But isn't it?
It's fascinating because like as a human
being,
right,
you're supposed to be like living in the
moment.
You're supposed to be enjoying the
moment like you are alive.
Is it just the inevitable doom of the
clock ticking in the background that
makes it so sad?
Is that what it is every morning?
For me,
I do not wake up on a morning without
thinking about how much time do I have
left,
when will I die,
stinks the great demise.
But I've been doing that since my early
mid thirties.
So.
Wow.
Well,
if you think about it,
it becomes inevitable.
I mean everyone bashing your lifestyle
because there wasn't an error.
The Sam Kinison era,
probably bad example.
Well he died in a drunk driving
accident.
He wasn't even drunk.
Yeah,
he was sober.
But where that was acceptable and then
it became unacceptable.
So I'm,
you know,
I can name me and Ron White as the two
comics have any tenure that still
actually drink heavily and smokes
cigarettes.
He smoked cigars,
whatever.
Dumb or rarely drinks pretty heavily.
Does he?
Yeah,
he's pretty open about it.
He drinks pretty much every night,
right?
Yeah.
We heard he's not known for it.
Like he doesn't,
he doesn't bring it up a lot.
He doesn't walk out onstage at three
drinks under his arm,
like Neil Hamburger.
Right.
But for real now he'll go up there with
a drink or so.
But he's such a great guy.
I just saw them last week or the salt of
the Earth Chi,
that expression.
He said no more true than that guy.
He's just so sweet.
He's such a lovable guy.
Anyway,
I see him.
I just can't wait to hug them.
You know,
we're on a cruise ship and I was just a
passenger.
It was the impractical jokers,
which I fucking love their shows so
much.
They put on a fan crews and I've founded
and I go bingo.
And I.
Who is impractical jokers?
Jokers.
Yeah,
it was two weeks ago.
Who are they?
It's untrue TV.
Uh,
one of the worst networks out there.
Oh,
that's for guys.
They're all friends and they do pranks
like you would do with your buddies.
It's not like fucking Ashton Kutcher on
punked.
They just dare each other to do shots
fired
is when you explained it doesn't,
it doesn't.
I'm the first to say Ashton Kutcher,
the guy you haven't heard about an eight
years is a Douche.
But when you explain the explaining the
Tru TV print,
practical jokers
is kind of.
It doesn't sound that funny.
But when you see it is fantastic.
Genuine,
and that's what I would say.
For the record,
I met Ashton Kutcher.
It was very nice,
but does show sucked and I love his
camera.
He was a very nice guy.
I worked with them on that CVS hidden
camera thing.
I mean I only got to talk to him once,
but he was very friendly.
This is totally a valet driver is if
he's.
He's a fake al.
What idiot would just hand their keys to
anybody.
Well,
anyone who goes to a valet just as
smarmy tone though,
she's a douche.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
almond med almost got in a fistfight
with um,
travis barker.
Appears a mad.
I'm mad they were doing this prank on
punked or a met med was telling me the
stories he got to get like in travis
barker's face who's travis barker from
blink one,
eight two.
The drummer covered in tattoos,
right?
He's from blink one eight.
Two,
right.
Really nice guy.
Really cool guy,
amazing drummer and just an interesting
cat all around.
But he,
I guess he just doesn't take any shit
from people.
And ahmed ahmed like is a big guy,
like amount of meds.
You know,
200 plus pounds,
probably six foot one or something like
that.
He's a pretty big guy and except for the
intimidating part,
he's not intimidating.
No scared of.
I'm at a mad.
If you didn't know him,
he didn't have a suicide vest on
me.
I'd be the first to say,
how dare you.
How dare you.
I stole that from you,
but my
regular nomenclatures.
How dare you.
So joe rogan.
It's not even mine.
I mean that's just,
it's out there.
I don't knoW.
Hello.
Nice lady.
Hi.
I know I stole that from a brendan
walsh.
Oh,
hi ladies.
nice lady.
I use that all the time.
Hey,
nice ladies.
A good one that's so fucking pejorative
but not.
It's like you don't remember name in it.
Instead of saying,
hey baby,
hey,
good.
Nice lady.
In a way with a nice lady.
I actually asked them once they go,
did I steal that from you?
You don't know.
That's a good one is brendan's walsh
always said it,
but I'm assuming he said just meet a
funny guy that like fuck it works in the
kitchen and he has great lines.
You forget where you got them from and
then all of a sudden you're like,
you're all going,
hey now or you know,
hey,
there are whatever this means that I use
all the time.
And I stole that from captain rowdy's
wife,
ms dot kimmy is a comic gold comic
captain rowdy.
And she answered the phone.
It'd be for rowdy and she'd go,
please hold.
I fucking use that ever since.
That's hilarious.
Please hold.
Eddie bravo had a,
these prescription pharmaceutical
companies calling him up.
Apparently he had used his money or uses
number other to uh,
like on a credit card order and bought
some pharmaceutical drugs.
So they would just randomly call him.
I,
they gave out his number so he would
just be fucking sit around and they
would call him and ask him if he wants
to buy various drugs.
They sound different.
Canada.
This was back when they could do that.
So any baba would put phone down.
Who would walk away for five minutes?
I'll be right back.
I just got to find my.
I know I got my money here.
So harlow's saying,
well yeah,
I'm definitely buying some stuff and he
put the phone down the street that's
called a stroker.
I'm from the old telemarketing days.
Oh,
that's a stroke or someone who would
just purposely keep you on the phone and
fuck with you for as long as they could,
which is actually a good move while we
were fucking defrauding people.
So you can't hold it against him.
No,
it's fun if you get it.
That's a smart one.
You got a smart one.
You got one that Didn't fall into the
hive.
I hate bounty hunters just because their
cocks.
I meAn you have a point,
a stroke or as a point.
Yeah,
stroke or as a point for sure.
Random phone calls like especially the
unsolicited phone calls.
Fuck them.
So all just get the fucking robots now
and what I get now,
I don't know if anyone else gets this.
They mimic your own phone number,
so it will have my same area,
code and prefix,
and then just screw up the last four
numbers a little bit.
So you,
I Assume the psychology is,
you recognize that phone number and then
answer it and then you go,
oh fuck,
that's my phone number.
And now you're listening to a bot call.
Do you want to extend your warranty?
You have a liMited time.
How many people actually buy into those?
I mean,
it has to be worthwhile.
Otherwise they wouldn't just keep doing
it.
I said,
well,
it's a robot.
it's a fucking computer.
So if you could just hit a program and
then go off to whatever you do,
selling shoes.
Some people are just really fucking
lonely too.
That's one thing to take into
consideration.
My grandfather,
before he died,
my grandmother died and then my,
it was one of those classic stories
where my grandmother dies and then my
grandfather dies a year later,
just just didn't want to live.
But in that year that you didn't visit,
he got lonely and I would take all
around here,
man in that,
uh,
in That year,
um,
he got addicted to buying things from
catalogs like you'd like he was,
he was,
he was getting cancer and was he in his
forties to know,
I mean just like was buying things that
they would call him up and they would
like offer him like catalogs and stuff
like that.
And he would,
you know,
who get the catalogs,
he would order things from the catalogs
and it became like a problem.
Like you,
he just would get it just like his wife
was gone and who know,
his wife was there his whole life.
So it's like you don't have anybody to
talk to.
I think part of you just goes insane.
Like part of you Blows a fuse,
like the normal inputs just not there.
Like usually it's you and the wife
and the husband,
you and the,
you know,
and then it's gone and they're like,
where's that thing that's part of my
life?
It's like a part of you dies,
you know?
And that they really do just want to die
and that's how they go.
How do you correlAte that to shopping?
This is my beef with fucking hoarders is
hoarders.
We'll do a montage like intervention
does.
Well.
Then her husband left for another woman
and then she started
stockIng the basement full of dollar
stores.
Shit.
I don't know that.
That,
that the cause and effect.
There's no scientific.
Your psych intervention,
hey,
tell me one bad thing that ever happened
to you and we'll do a montage about
that.
And that's why you're a fucking crack
addict is though.
No scientific proof.
That's why you're a crack addict.
That they try to pin it on something.
There's plenty of people who had great
childhoods that are fucking crack
addicts,
but they need to have some reason this a
chicks would fucking self help books all
over their shelf.
Why thing?
It's not an either or thing.
I think that's part of it.
Like there's a lot of people that have
drug addictions because of abuse,
right?
We,
I think we all know them because a lot
of people that get involved in drug
addiction because they were abused as a
child and whatever fuse blew.
They're like constantly trying to put
out that fire.
Right.
There's that.
But then there's also people that they
just fucking can't do it.
They just can't drink or they can't.
They can't do drugs.
They just can't.
They do it and then they get sharp eyes
and they're fucking gone.
They're just off to the races and we've
all.
We've all met people.
I know sean rouse is what you're saying,
but i'M saying it.
Bravo,
bravo is figured out how to pull in
though.
My point is your grandpa just like the
shit out of catalogs because he's bored.
I'm going to die soon.
let me just buy some shit and jack up a
credit card because I'm not going to be
around and pay this bill.
Once the family investigated,
that wasn't the case,
but I can understand why you would think
that for your grandpa specifically,
but he was.
People correlate.
Yeah.
He was so old country though.
He was born in Italy.
He was as old countries,
you get grew up on a farm,
taught me how to break a rabbit's neck.
I kill a rabbit.
When I grew up in a place,
there were no catalogs
die.
I better take advantage of all these new
fangled way like magic.
There was always the big thing That my
grandfather worked in a factory that
made a part for the atomic bomb.
Wow.
It was like one of those things that
you,
the whole family would talk about.
You know,
grandpa worked in a factory that made a
part for them
bomb wah,
wah wah.
It was like,
you know,
like sort of a badge of pride and some
sort of weird fucking way.
I think that's why he drank because he
knew he killed all those people in nigga
sakhi you didn't even.
Oh,
a guy with no conscience.
He was in.
He was a great guy.
My grandfather was the one of the nicest
guys of all time.
He was like,
even for Back then,
it's a hard time,
you know,
he was not a hard man at all.
He was the nicest guy.
When someone dies,
people say,
and he was such a sweet man and a nice
man and my dad,
even to this day when I was writing this
book above my mother,
oh,
your father was the sweetest person
ever.
He really was.
And I couldn't even say that about my
mother.
She was a real cunt towards the end.
She was a fucking bitter,
spiteful,
needy at the end.
At the beginning was just someone who
had a kid too young.
I met her like three quarters in and she
was great.
She was on the show.
He went back and in that book,
because my memory's shit and I watched
the episode with my mom and your mom
somewhere out there on some ceo or some
shit.
Right,
right.
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
Uh,
and like there's a lot of things in the
book that sounded like bullshit and I
know just sound like I got laid for the
first time when I was nine years old
before you could come.
And that sounds like that's on that
episode where the site was me and you
and they,
uh,
we had cards.
Okay.
Which one of us,
we had embarrassing things from our
childhood and our mothers were on like
jeopardy style and a.
Okay.
Which one of us did this and mine was
who lost his virginity in third grade in
a church and bang,
my mom's slaps the button.
That's my boy.
That was the name of the game.
And she.
I'm like,
you're verifying everything in this
book.
That sounds like bullshit on tape.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
Lot of stuff.
Do you ever have stories that you.
You will only tell if there's someone in
the room to verify because otherwise you
sound like a liar.
Yeah,
it sounds crazy.
Yeah.
She verified five different stories that
are in the book.
Well,
you remember when we had your mom review
porn?
Yeah,
she was fucking great at it.
She was great.
She would watch these dvds and review
them.
It was really funny.
It was humorous.
IT was.
It was really funny.
She was good.
So I,
I saw her at her best.
That's when I knew your mats once she
started drinking again was right after
the man show.
Oh no,
really?
She had been like 22 years sober.
She was sneaking it.
She'd be drinking cough syrup because
she,
she's a lifelong menthol smoker,
so she always had a cough.
So anytime you went to that filthy
apartment,
she had a little shot glass of cough
syrup.
So she was kinda like weaning or way
back into drinking,
but using the
fucking dollar store robitussin.
I remember talking about it on my first
cd,
year 2001 probably when.
Yeah,
I think back then you could get the real
shit.
I had a.
I wouldn't get real shit.
She was a dollar store for you,
nicole.
Like nicole would fuck you up.
Back then.
There was a comic that used to get one
of the guys who worked at a rascals in
west orange.
There was a comic he used to get.
One of the guys worked there to go buy
him bottles of nyquil.
He would just drink bottles of fucking
my,
uh,
when my brother was in the marine corps
in okinawa,
there was a whole bunch of them.
They called themselves the robo raiders
because they would drink robot testing
until they hallucinate.
Fucking listen to this.
oh,
the regular nyquil I think had coding
and it didn't have jamie,
you could get so fucked up like an
amazing way.
I,
uh,
I got to do it.
That's why I've had to morphine
experiences.
One of them was in the hospital after I
had knee surgery.
They gave me this thing that you could
press and you can press it.
Every time you press it you get more and
more.
And I was like,
oh,
well let's being high score.
I'm like,
I am in agony.
They just,
they drilled some shit into my knee,
replaced a ligament and cut one and took
out bone and screwed it together.
It's fucking agony.
So I'm just like,
oh pam,
pam,
and it just took me to this amazing
place of bliss.
And I'm like,
well,
no wonder why that shit's hard to get.
No wonder why it's illegal.
And then the next time I never would
take medicine,
but I got a bad cold and I just needed
to sleep and I couldn't sleep.
So I took some nyquil and it was
amazing.
It was the same feeling that I had when
I had surgery.
It's like the nyquil just took me to
this butte,
fell back into the most amazing down
pillow.
Just have love to
people that are a beautiful jagged on
the vicodin percocet.
So an opiate where I've taken vicodin.
It did nothing.
Even when I had one surgery in my adult
life was an umbilical hernia and they
gave it to me as a painkiller and I
didn't feel any pain,
but I didn't feel any high.
And I'm like,
maybe this just doesn't hurt.
Why buddy that got into vicodin
for writing,
he would write on it.
He would take vicodin and write music.
That was his thing.
He loved to crush up vicodins and then
he would take it and I don't know how he
would do it,
snort it or whether you would just
swallow them,
but he would,
uh,
he would say that as music had become
very creative native
and it would do that.
I can't write on anything but a fear.
Seriously.
I write sober,
afraid I'll
write some shit down when I'm drunk
ideas and then sober me will have to go
back and clean them up.
Okay.
I got at best I can remember the premise
and now I have to make this good.
But uh,
there's,
there's drugs that are good for stage
cocaine,
which I'm not a regular user of,
but I've had shows where I'm just tired
of saying this shit and do a bump before
stage.
It's great for stage,
but for writing nothing other than see
fear and coffee.
Joey diaz says that coke was terrible
for him,
for the stage.
Joey said that coke would make them lock
up.
It would make them feel evil and make
them feel greedy.
He goes away.
Would would take out the love.
The amount of toke joey diaz was
probably doing is different than a small
bic cap
that I would do like a 48 hour energy
drink.
Do you remember that time?
We did a musHrooms the day of the war.
We took this as,
I've never had cocaine,
but I did have this fucking coca leaves
tea from [inaudible] and he had this
montay to cocoa tea was tea that was
made out of cocoa leaves and you would,
uh,
you would drink it and I just couldn't
shut the fuck up.
RememBer I was talking to you about,
you and I were having this conversation
about it.
I was like,
this is what coke is like,
oh my god,
this is awful.
We've always said you're terrified of
trying because if I like,
you know,
go fucking hay wire.
And I think I'm terrified of it because
when I grew up I saw two people that it
was pretty close to a completely ruined
their lives.
One was a really good friend and anoTher
one was a really good friend's cousin
and I watched their life just go to
shit.
I've seen the same thing.
I saw a couple of fat girls get thin.
Do you remember when they had phen phen?
Do you remember?
If I remember existing,
what is,
I knew a girl diet pill.
His fucking truck stops speed basically,
but sold under a different marketing
umbrella.
Well,
it was really fucking bad for you.
I knew a girl who was god on it and she
went from being unfortunately like
plump.
She was heR name,
ellen burstyn and requiem for a dream.
No,
no.
It's a different girl.
She was like a little plump.
Three people out there got that
reference.
Good.
But that was a good movie though.
Requiem for a dream was the shit.
I almost forgotten about that movie.
I said the fen phen lost a ton of
weight,
looked amazing,
but then started feeling really,
really bad.
Like you kNow,
you get like fucking heart issues,
man.
Me,
you were on essentially you're on speed
speed for a fuckinG year and after a
while your hearts like,
hey,
fuck.
Had some oil in.
This engine will Run at about 88,000
fucking rpm.
She looked amazing though,
man.
I mean she went from being a girl who
had this really pretty faCe.
It just couldn't get her body in order
for whatever reason,
her diet,
drinking and a lot of just a story.
This weekend on a newser is where I Go
for my read less no more or some dumb
shit.
Some girl in Wisconsin froze to death,
leaving a party in a tank top and shorts
at six below zero security cameras
caught her walking like a thousand feet
and then just curled up and fucking
died.
Oh my god.
That's the vanity.
Can't go.
Just underdressed to be sexy.
That's why it chick always wants your
coat.
When she goes,
I'm going to dress all sexy and then
it's 25 degrees out.
Can I wear your coat?
No.
I brought a coat because I know it's
fucking cold outside or how dare you.
First of all,
this girl was drunk.
So you gotta think this girl has
friends,
right?
How the fuck our friends?
Like listen,
if we're all hanging out.
Okay.
And it's fucking six below zero.
And I go,
where's doug?
Where the fuck is doug was doug.
Have you seen doug?
I'm thinking you blacked out when
wandering off into the fucking arctic.
I'm going to go outside looking for you.
I would immediately,
if we were all hammered,
if I knew we were fucked up,
so she's leaving a bar and she's fucked
up and her friends don't pay attention,
just curls up on the ground,
dies like there's more to her personal
story,
but I'm using that as an extreme example
of when you see chips waiting in line at
a bar like chill coot,
charlie's in Alaska and there's a line
around the block at midnight in the
winter and it's freezing,
but they're all dressed up horsley and
fish nets and whatever because they
don't say rather be in agony than look
bad.
There's so much power.
If you're a girl with a hot body and you
have fish nets on and you walk into a
bar and you have like black leather
shorts and fish nets and high heels and
you have a nice ass and great legs,
you are a queen.
I'm like,
you are god,
and you know what?
If you're a fat girl that can outlast
her,
you're going to get the same fucking
action.
So the same doug.
It is the lady.
It's the same,
the girl with the fucking,
she gets all the attention.
She might get on instagram and get
fucking millions of friends and
squarespace starts giving her money.
Millions of real honest friends like
salted.
The earth close to me,
but enough is it just fills the void.
Like it doesn't have to be that void.
The kardashians made it
started that fire and then she fucking
vanished before the bomb went off.
she got out and vanished.
She got out,
she got the game.
Well,
it's like,
oh yeah,
just like old comics.
They didn't get out of the game.
They got replaced.
Yeah,
but we got out of the game.
She didn't need the money.
Well,
she develops a bunch of business
ventures that are extremely successful.
Yeah.
Like she makes a fucking ungodly amount
of money and decided to like lay.
Well,
she
realized that the ego has a horriBle
byproduct.
Yes.
Like that fame comes at a price and the
price became too much.
She didn't need to be seen with beaver
hanging out.
It's probably Brittany Spears,
but they're all the same.
I'll do that though,
and I was like,
there was a time where girls are just
showing their pussy was amazing times.
It was like right when social media
first started popping.
Those girls were fucking gangster about
it.
They just said,
listen,
I'm going to put a photographer in a
place where no fucking photographer
would ever be and I'm going to pretend
that that guy just accidentally took
pictures of my pussy because what the
fuck?
Let's a guy get on his knees looking up
your dress as you get out of the
bentley.
That shit doesn't happen.
It's not what happened.
They have people,
they have security teams that rival the
secret service to make sure that doesn't
happen.
yet it happened to you in the most
flattering way on the day.
You weren't having your period and you
shaved your bush.
How amazing.
the luck of that photographer,
they always shave their bush.
That's where porn.
One more just one.
If amy schumer shaved her posts,
had some kind of particular razzies
shot.
Upper gi,
becAuse this is my amy schumer thing.
I know you don't wAnt to get into the
stealing jokes thing because I don't
know,
I'm out in the business do good business
to be honest,
but when she stArted doing the,
I'm going to pose naked when what?
My three rolls of fat,
because that's what a woman really is in
hollywood won't touch a person like
that.
I have a fucking grotesquely hanging
ball sack.
How bad and I wouldn't say it's worse
than most.
Do you remember joey from?
I'm a huge shock.
I had that picture dick him ball sack.
If you have a huge dick to compensate
for the ball sack,
then it kind of looks all proportionate.
I have a small dick with hanging balls
are one hangs way lower than the other
and I would never like do some kind of a
annie liebowitz fucking photo spread
going,
you know what?
The porn industry doesn't accept people
like me,
but this is the reality of cock and
balls and I'm just going to show it.
You know what?
No one wants to fucking see it.
It bothers me that people who you just.
It's not hollywood that tells you what's
attractive,
but I.
I think she's funny.
I think amy schumer's funny.
I actually watched her comedy special
and laughed out loud alone on my lonely
couch,
but as laughing out loud.
She's verY funny.
She's funny on podcasts.
She's really funny on radio shows.
She's very quick.
I liked her a lot,
but it's not just people will go,
you have to accept my body style.
I didn't not accepted.
I just didn't buy a magazine to see it.
well I don't.
Do I get where they're coming from in a
way?
Yeah,
but I.
But they go like everything.
There's like low places that it goes
where I don't agree anymore and that's
one of those things like,
ah,
if she wants to be like,
hey,
look at my fat.
Who gives a fuck?
High five.
Why not a guy can do a joey can do it.
Joe.
He does it all the time.
I mean,
in one of the pictures that I had for
vegas that jamie puts,
jamie made this picture is what joey
from like the joey karate days when he
was at his heaviest,
he had this giant gut and he's got a
shirt off and he's like doing karate
moves.
I mean it's because it's funny.
I mean if I support joey being funny
there.
Melissa mccarthy is fucking victor.
It's an ad for the mgm grand.
Were there on March 4th doing it to be
funny as opposed to a woman that's
hollywood overweight trying to say,
well,
you know what?
This can be sexy to joey's not doing
that to go.
There's are sexy too.
As a fellow comic I always have to look
at it from the perspective of like,
alright,
well what is she trying to do?
Is she trying to be funny?
Or is she trying to say I don't give a
fuck.
She's doing one of those things.
Right.
And either one of those things is.
I'll tell you my opinion of what she's
doing is what I hope you fell into that
I fell into when we were at that same
age where we both started getting
compared to bill hicks and getting too
much fucking picks.
Pressure.
yes.
And you kind of try to live up to it.
I think she's so big that she feels like
she is the voice for all females because
they're telling her she is and she's
probably overcompensating on some level.
Well,
she's probably overwhelmed by the g
force of fame.
I mean the g force of family she's
experienced and experienced it really
quickly.
Like amy was on the show.
I get to z force of fame and not even
two years ago.
Right.
So,
uh,
less than a year and a half ago she was
nowhere near as famous as she is now
going to go to africa.
Like chapelle just to get away from this
shit.
She's going to become trans black.
And she does,
she have,
um,
she's,
I don't even think she's like 30.
Is she 30,
32?
I think she's 32.
She's really young,
man.
look,
when I was 32,
I was fucking retarded.
I'm retarded now and I'm 48,
but that's when I was 30,
20 fucking,
hey,
I was billing ex best friend and you
want to do a video with you though?
Shit.
I Have to live up to that.
Well,
there was always that like you'd get
compared to a little kicks,
like,
oh my god,
I can't be myself.
There was like,
you did want to have your own sense of
humor.
You wanted to live up to this void that
was
left behind.
There was a.
there was a fucking great.
Pete,
you know jamie from the atlanta
punchline.
No guy ran a great guy.
I ran into him at the comedy store the
other day and there was a.
Sure.
I do know,
but I knew that I guarantee,
you know,
did you work at atlanta?
She ever do the punchline.
All I remember is bad shows.
Fucking one of the all time best comedy
clubs.
It was a great club.
They just went under the real parking
issue,
so they're moving to a new location,
but they took apart the old place and
save pieces of the stage and saved
pieces of the green room and the green
room had like shitty fake wood paneling
and on that I'm actually actually be
would,
it might be real wood paneling,
but they went on it,
it said so he doesn't get sued.
No,
no,
because I'm kidding.
I'm going to have it here.
Um,
yeah,
there's.
Yeah,
there's one piece I said,
can I please have the piece that says
quit trying to be hicks?
I took a picture of it and I put it up
on the line back when it was stolen from
the Austin Green room.
I don't think they did.
I think this was,
it was an old fucking club that the club
had been around forever,
but everybody was saying that at the
time there was a million halfassed hicks
and that's what you could call them
tours.
Yeah.
Well,
like right now there's like 100 of
towels.
There's so many guys who talk like dave,
there's so many,
there's so many fucking that tells,
you know,
there's a bunch of.
Patrice is when patrice was alive.
There's a few.
Patrice has quite a few hedbergs oh yeah
man,
but they've kind of branched out into
the road,
which is what happens man.
It's like in the beginning it's what's,
what's awkward is that we're watching
it,
but we all kind of went through like I
had a bad richard jeni period,
man where it was onstage and I realized
I was like open mic level one year in
and I was onstage and myself.
I was like,
oh my god,
I'm definitely stealing the way richard
jenny talks.
Like I was talking just like I'm the
same cadence.
I wasn't even being myself,
but I realized that like it's just
because I admired them and I was scared.
I was trying to figure out how to do it
on my own.
So it becomes a lot of these guys.
I think that's what happens.
Like there's guys that had been compared
to hedberg then you can't really say
that anymore.
Like you watch them now and you go,
oh,
he's found his own little weird thing,
but hannibal burress,
when I first saw hannibal it fucking
brilliant.
I go,
wow,
he sounds like hedberg it,
and then I go,
I think hedbergs stole sounding black
little bit,
man,
a little bit.
He had one of my all time favorite jokes
about bananas.
Someone said,
do want a frozen banana?
I said,
no,
but I want a regular banana latest.
So yes,
we going through the litany of our
favorite hedberg and it tells,
and I don't have a girlfriend,
but I do have a girl that would be very
upset if she heard me say that.
Yeah,
I knew that girl like that.
So his jokes,
a lot of them
were reality based even though that's
probably why he hated the Steven Wright
comparison where he was saying real
shit.
He really did give free bread to a duck
at subway like that.
These things actually happened and he
wrote it in a way that was hilarious.
You are with them.
Sorry.
When he wrote the joker,
bertha tennis,
we played tennis down.
There
is first a letterman's special.
He did the joke and he dropped my name
and I was all excited.
I played tennis with my friend doug,
and I realized,
no matter how good I get at tennis,
I'll never be as good as a wall.
He had a gang of them.
He was just one of those guys,
man.
Just very,
uh,
very unique.
It's very hard to compare him to someone
else.
He's just his own little weird category.
Fucking shock.
Croft has so much unreleased footage and
she's such a scared to put it.
So I don't know.
and like why wouldn't you put it out?
Well,
because she doesn't what she wants his
legacy to be righted.
She's a fuck up like all the rest of my
comic friends,
she doesn't get around his shit.
So it was stuff that he was working on.
He'd film everything.
Wow.
I have,
I have this 30 minute va.
Jesse made me from like 1993 that he
shot while we're on the road doing like
Montana run tribble gigs and vancouver
and he just shot and edited back in vhs
days.
It wasN't computer era.
You had to actually sit and edit this
and titled it for me and autographed it.
Two minutes just,
he's like break dancing in the winter on
some baron road onto a piece of
cardboard in Montana
were making out in a kitchen in some
fucking a comedy club in surrey,
bc.
And he fuckIng w we kiss in front of the
cooks just to disturb them.
And he pauses on it and plays.
I want to know what love is.
Just
he was doing that shit though in
[inaudible] 93.
And he,
we were co headlining a b room.
So we were cold,
middling basically,
right for no money.
I remember the night we got paid,
we were afraid we weren't going to get
paid because this club was definitely
going under.
Could tell.
And uh,
we're having,
we had to stay in the owner's house and
there's the,
the owner didn't even live there.
And there's stacks of dirty dishes
higher than the sink and it's just as
bare mattresses were sleeping on in the
basement.
and we're like,
we're going to get fucked out of our
money.
And thIs is when if you don't get paid,
you don't get home.
That's your gas.
That's everything.
And we finally got paid and then they're
taking us into downtown vancouver
salaries,
a suburb and the door guys that we're
cool,
we're going to take us out to party.
And I was,
they were telling me how hot the hookers
were in vancouver.
Streetwalkers oh,
but no,
they were.
Yeah,
we're,
we're driving past all these hookers.
I go,
these are really streetwalker hookers.
Fucking for me a game for you.
Not so much a.
And I'm like,
what's the minimum?
And whatever it was,
they said like 50 bucks.
And I go,
all right,
here's,
I think I got paid like 600 bucks or
something.
I go,
here's the rest of my money.
I'm just taking 50 bucks.
I can't get ripped off.
Drop me off next to her and picked me up
half an hour.
So they dropped me off.
I go up to her and the minimum is 100
bucks minimum.
Yeah.
Well I only have 50 cause they told me
it was 50.
Nope.
So I just sit on a bus bench next to a
book or working on a sidewalk for 29
more minutes waiting for my friend to
come pick me up.
Why would you go to a hooker with fifth,
1994 60 bucks.
That's what this.
The guys who dropped me off told me I
was fucking whatever.
Hobby 94.
so 20 slash 67.
Yeah,
something.
Something along those law.
ThInking about my dick,
dick made the worst choices in my life.
Vancouver is one of the strangest
fucking places because it's Canada,
but it's a.
It's almost like America,
Canada,
you know?
It's like,
it's so seattle.
It's like it's right there.
Like portland,
seattle.
It's almost,
it's more sanford,
cisco in the pc and yeah,
this piece of a lot.
There's a lot of wild people there to.
Vancouver's got a lot a.
While people will say it's almost like a
cisco,
but the ones that are conserved very.
It's almost like if anchorage fuck san
francisco,
it would make vancouver.
Right?
I was trying to think of a good heroin
city because there's a lot of heroin up
there,
but in anchorage or in know in
vancouver,
it's huge heroin that would go the place
we play.
Brian's never been tHere.
That's why he keeps booking me back.
Uh,
the rick shaw and it's in the heroin
district,
which they have a heroin,
might as well be,
you know,
wherever the,
all the fucking syrian refugees go.
Now.
There's lIke,
if you've ever seen a full street flea
market
that's a homeless people like every
single inch of the entire street across
the street from that gig is homeless
tents.
And you think,
oh,
is this an open air market?
No,
that's fucking homeless junkies.
All the entire sidewalk for four blocks
is just wandering,
vagabond junkie street people.
I don't want to erwin district look at
this.
Look at the picture now.
Fuck.
Yeah,
that's nuts.
Can I just say it's a very good deal.
So you get what you pay for in this
world,
right?
No,
no.
The door door door deal saw standing.
Jesus christ.
No,
that's an actual restaurant.
Don't you tell him,
hey man,
let's place blows.
Generally I do,
but sometimes I don't remember.
I explained the financial alternatives.
Yeah,
you can't.
You can't let that get involved in your
business.
Can't let the financial alternatives get
involved in your business.
Standing out in that back alley smoking
and as you're,
you're literally going,
can I get some duct tape for my pant
legs because there's rats are running so
rapidly that you're just thinking,
oh,
that could run up my leg.
THere's that many of them and raw
sewage,
thick raw sewage.
I was just thinking about the poor hook
and working for 50 bucks.
Keep fixating on that.
No,
she was 100 bucks.
I get lied.
Is there has to be a girl there that was
working for 50
drive through Utah and you go through a
drive through in st george and there's
this perfect platinum blonde 19 year old
working the drive through and you go to
fuck you doing here.
Well,
becauSe they all looked at good.
Oh,
I didn't get to Utah on toes in my
forties.
Well you haven't lived.
You know what I do love though is salt
lake city,
like doing standup and salt lake city,
it's like everything has got like a
little extra kick to it because it's
like because they don't get it,
they get it,
they don't get it.
I get it.
That type of entertainment.
So the ones that are into it are.
Yeah.
It's like playing the antarctic,
which I really want to do.
The antarctic.
Wow.
That's a space station station,
station station,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
I watched a documentary on that place
mat.
Murderous mcmurdo isn't mcmurdo.
Yeah,
I see.
I think everybody gets it now.
There's like pockets of people
everywhere.
They get it like so like salt lake city
is not.
It's not Just a giant mormon stronghold.
It's also a bunch of people that just
live theRe and it's beautiful.
And as far as the stigma,
so people would might issue the place
because I don't want to fuck salt lake.
Exactly.
And they're lIke,
no,
we're better now.
Well,
it's a good spot because of all those
things because it's underrated because
everyone's so scared that it's a cult
city and it is a fucking cult city by
the way.
Uh,
I,
I arrived at the airport like a few
months back,
landed as we're going down the
escalator.
You see these fucking people welcomed
back.
Elder michael,
like,
welcome back to the elders.
They're fucking 20 and they're calling
them elders
and they're coming back from convincing
some people that don't even have clean
water that they need to
embrace the joseph.
Yeah,
the mormon doctrIne.
That's why your water's dirty.
Joseph smith hasn't been here.
So bizarre man.
It's so bizarre.
They make them do it.
They make them go to these con.
That's like part of their gig is that
they have to proselytize.
They have to go to these weird places
and missions.
Yeah,
it's fucking nuts
span.
Comic friend of mine went on the
tabernacle tour.
What's that?
Touring the mormon tabernacle.
And they have a tour just like the
vatican would.
And you can tour the tabernacle and he
just kept asking about the mormon
meadows massacre.
And uh,
I think it was 18,
57,
I know as nine slash 11 where they
murdered the mormons,
murdered all these people and oh yeah,
fucking unknown story.
But google it at home.
Mormons meadows massacre.
So,
uh,
yeah.
But what about that more dot better.
And they've finally,
someone pulled them aside.
Sarah,
I'd like to show you something this way.
And they showed them right out the
fucking door because he wouldn't stop
with the mormons metal massacre.
DId you know all about mitt romney?
Did you know the whole Mexico thing?
No.
Oh,
let me tell you something.
So beautiful.
Mitt romney's family,
like mitt romney's dad wanted to be
president,
but he couldn't be president because he
was born in Mexico because mitt romney's
family fleed to Mexico.
When they made polygamy illegal,
when they made it illegal to marry a
bunch of chicks,
which is a part of their church.
They went,
fuck you.
we're going to Mexico because back in
the 18 hundreds didn't mean anything to
live in the United States or Mexico
because everybody's on a fucking horse.
It's not like being on a Horse over here
is way more awesome than being on a
horse over here.
It's bullshit.
You go back and forth as you will near a
running stream.
I'm better thaN you.
Yeah.
it's all that mattered.
Especially in the 18 hundreds of the
porter was nothing.
It was nonexistent,
so they didn't want it here to the new
United States Laws against their
religious freedom to marry 15,
12 year olds,
so they decided to move to Mexico.
So His whole fucking family is from
Mexico.
Mitt romNey's family.
His dad's from Mexico.
My mom's from Mexico.
They're aLl a part of the mormon cult
from down there or religion as it were,
but they have fucking guns and they
fight off the cartel because they get
kidnapped.
There's a bunch of fuckIng crazy shit
that goes on down there.
There's a couple of different families
and vice went down there and did a doc
on it to notice how I say doc because
I'm working in the industry like an
abbreviated shit.
It makes me look cool.
TwItter trains you to abbreviate.
I know.
It's terrible.
No,
it's good.
They did one of their hours
or one of their videos online.
I'll just say that and it was all about
these mormons that live in Mexico still
and they have a fucking compound,
like an armed waco style compound and
that's where he came from.
So essentially it's like that guy from
david koresh.
Imagine david koresh,
his son.
Okay.
Moves to Mexico
and runs for president.
That is what it's like.
It's like that similar.
I mean oBviously like dude crush I guess
like shots and federal agents chill like
that.
So it gets a little trickier,
but there's this branches out into a
Whole bunch of uva,
but these fucking people have.
They have,
they have guns and they have to fight
off the bad guys in Mexico.
Like they're stuck dOwn there like this
is where they've decided to like look
white people that look like they're from
fucking Utah and they were living in
Mexico.
It's weird as fuck,
man.
It's really weird.
It's real weird.
But if we started a compounded because
our opinions are not popular,
fuck this.
I'm going to go to some other country or
place where no one fucks with us and
we're going to have this death valley
party for life.
Why Not?
Definitely.
Why not?
No,
I'm don't get me wrong.
Mitt romney for having a fucked up
parents.
He was.
He's not down there fucking tweLve year
olds.
Not warren jeffs.
you will.
You can't even belIeve brain.
David koresh.
If david koresh gotten to situation,
we had a bunch of people and he made
them all have their wives sleep with
them like that's fucking his keys.
Stopped calling it a cult and start
calling it a fan base.
All of a sudden you're living the free
market.
American dream.
The problem is you label it.
It's all about tHe nomenclature.
you got to label it correctly.
That's what the whole scientology thing
was about.
The nomenclature of whether it's a
church or whether it's.
So.
Yeah.
That koresh guy was charismatic and he
had a lot of fans,
right?
Yeah.
That's really what use them.
If they're having a good time,
who's to say his comedy stinks?
Yeah,
and like these guys,
if they want to stay a deal's a deal,
you've got to let the cult leader fuck
your wife.
That's just how it goes and it's not
like we can't do the same thing in
comedy.
Hey,
sorry buddy.
She cAme with me after the show.
Jesus says it's okay,
man.
Do.
Did you really move with the comedian?
How terrible.
I'm leaving this colt.
It's funny that even in 2016 there's
ones that will buy into and ones who
were like,
that was fucking stupid.
You know,
there's like as a culture,
as a society,
we get the main ones.
It's almost like political parties
because it's just as ridiculous to have
the democrats or libertarians or the
green party or because it's ridiculous.
Just having leaders is ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
All of it's ridiculous.
It's all in some ancient hominid
bullshit that we have stuck in our
genetics.
We think we have to have one leader that
stands over all of us and fucking
where's the special suit and puts his
hand up.
We all applaud.
It's retarded.
It's retarded,
it's ancient.
It's so archaic.
It's just fucking stupid.
We've got to,
yeah,
but if you're the first guy to not,
then you're.
Then you're a dildo.
Well,
it's someone's going to have to figure
out how to break it.
Like they're going to have to like it.
It almost is going to take it and you
know what?
It's going to take no one running for
president.
The charIsmatic leader,
unfortunately,
and you'd have to get a charismatic
leader that definitely didn't want to
fuck.
Listen.
Absolutely.
Everyone follow me and not following me.
Yes.
That's the move.
People don't want to fuck fend for
themselves.
I think we're gonna have to come up with
in like in our lifetime,
people are going to realize that there's
a lot of things that are just in place
that were we were born with and the
people that set them up,
they just did not have access to the
information that they needed to form
those decisions.
Like the reason why they started off the
electoral college.
All the bullshit that we have to contend
with today is because it made sense in
1776.
It made sense.
They were just trying to piece together
this thing,
but to stick with that,
to stick with that,
every time someone says,
you know what,
in the constitution it says,
well,
you know what,
if you can make a better constitution,
make it.
If you can make that's going to
progress.
I think there's a bunch of things we
have to agree on if we want to call
ourselves America because otherwise we
become some like we've become like a
fuckin
become like the mantra with you and I
versus the mantra with adam and jimmy
comes up with the same name.
It's like,
what is this fucking thing?
This is not what I signed up for.
Everybody signed up for America and the
idea of America,
it's supposed to be freedom of speech.
That's a big one.
Right?
But how many people today are in trouble
for talking about?
Shit.
I mean,
how many people today are in trouble for
revealing information or talking out
about things that they changed the
ellsberg verses snowden or chelsea
manning?
Sure.
Yeah.
Ellsberg's a fucking hero.
Okay.
You went with chelsea?
Yeah,
like I did the correct gender.
I did,
yes.
I had a lot of full of stimulants and
viagra and the fucking chick I thought
was a short thing,
turned out to be a dude.
No,
no,
no.
The dale done.
So.
Oh,
you've researched online.
She on a hey arrows guide is added.
Dude.
I can't tell if that's a dude from the
picture.
I'm just going to not call.
Sometimes arrows got better than you.
Porn is looking up.
Hookers you could actually get and then
jerking off.
No one.
You know what?
For 800 bucks I could get her,
but I'd have to wait 35 minutes.
I reaLly think the girl in that photo is
actually going to come to your door.
They should take your credit card and
sell it to India really should.
Whatever they do to your credIt card
when you fucking to call and leave that
visa card for the deposit.
Got you.
And love the people.
Actually buy credit card protection
without knowing that.
you know what?
if you didn't sign for it,
it's the credit card that's eating it,
not you.
Where I went to The Bahamas once and
came back and there was a charge for
thousand
plus dollars for porcelain tile.
Yeah,
that's what I do when I'm on vacation.
I bought it porcelain kitchen tile.
$7,000 worth of credit card company eats
it wise.
That's what they have to do.
So all those,
you know,
Interested anyone steal your identity or
steal your credit card will protect you
against that.
Know the fucking vehcile,
eat it.
Fuck you.
leave that shit laying out and then I'll
say,
I didn't sign for it.
I,
I have this idea about information that
money essentially.
It doesn't really mean anything anymore,
right?
It's not backed by gold.
It's just all stored up on a computer
somewhere.
We agree that $100,
$100,
but the.
So that's the theory.
That's fact,
but it's data.
It's just just ones and zeros.
There's no physical thing.
Well,
the thing what's happening with
technology is technology is bringing
people and ideas like closer together
quicker.
Like if you have an idea,
you tweeted a fucking 100,000 people
might get ahold of that idea within a
couple of seconds,
right?
Videos,
you put up a video,
it gets crazy,
it gets viral.
A million people and I see it in day or
two that the more technology improves,
the quicker and easier it is to get to
people quicker.
It easy.
It is to communicate well.
Money is information and communication.
It's just about information.
We might come a time where the
bottleneck is money,
like we can't have possessions in order
to be this one in order to everyone
connects together and some sort of a
weIrd artificial evolution induced like
connection to technology that we're
inevitably going to have.
Well,
it's common.
It's going to happen.
The bottleneck might be money.
I think we're going to get to a point
where money's not real and instead of
drinking,
because I had no idea what you said,
but I nodded a lot.
I think we're going to get to a point
where there's no more money.
I think that's what's going to happen.
We're going to get to some weird point.
We're gonna get to a lot of weird points
that we're not going to be here for and
the differences.
You have kids so you worry about it a
little bit more than I do.
Probably go.
Wow.
Well I mean everything from 100 years
ago that you could not possibly imagine
that are happening now is happening now.
Yeah,
so a lot of weird shit we can't even
imagine will happen and I just won't be
here for it,
but isn't it really cool at the same
time?
It's not.
It's not like it's not negative.
It's like even the loss of moneY,
like this idea,
like look,
everyone's the negative people that are
the problem,
global warming and yes,
shit's going to go underwater and it's
not going to be the Maldives anymore,
but it's going to be warmer in Wisconsin
and what?
You shouldn't be fucking in having that
many kids next to what coastline
katrina,
we're going to rebuild new orleans.
Oh,
The water's rising and you live under
the sea level of fuck you drown your
kids.
You fucking asshole.
Courageous.
You're not going to get to host our
event.
Now emc,
our event,
after that,
we have rescinded our offer.
Mr stan ho,
we,
uh,
we cannot endorse your fingers out there
if you're going to Bring your own booze
and poured into a candidate drag club
soda bottle and you're mixing it with
club soda.
Make sure your realize Which club sodas,
vodka.
I just poured a whole fuck load of vodka
in this thinking.
It was a shake and get real.
Oh my god,
I can't say the wrong thing.
There's a lot of vodka.
Vodka.
Oh no,
no,
there's a lot of it's ice.
Sorry you couldn't fucking pro.
I know I have full.
As long as they don't try to smoke your
weed and things go south.
It could be worse.
You could be drinking himself.
Super.
It's been a long week.
What will we,
what were you just talking about?
You were just sayIng something that was
really interesting.
What the fuck did you just say?
Just before that.
Oh.
About worrying about the future more
because I have children.
That's probably true,
but you know what?
It's not just that.
It's not even necessarily worrying.
It's about like if I see a pattern and
then I see some things happening,
I think I see a bunch of things that are
moving in a certain direction because
just like you,
I don't have a conventional job.
I'm not overwhelmed with having to do
shit that other people want me to do,
so most of my day spent thinking about
shit that I want to think about,
so when I look at this whole weird
pattern like what are we doing?
Like what is this society doing?
Were some weird fucking builder creature
that's making better and better
technology every year because that's
ultimately what we're doing,
but forget about all the shit about the
kardashians and all the shit about the
democrats and the liberals and
transgender rights and we're making
better and better technology.
All that other stuff just allows us to
have fun while we're doing it.
Just creates conflict and resolutions
and $50 hookers and all that shit just
rose up together,
but the.
At the end of the day,
what we're doing is making better and
better technology.
That's all we're doing.
That's the one constant.
If we stay alive,
we innovate,
we stay alive,
we keep going.
But if innovation,
if you have to keep making more shit
just to make people buy more shit.
Like,
isn't this shit we have enough.
Exactly.
it's true.
Yeah.
It isn't us since we live a comfortable
lifestyle.
There was some story today where,
uh,
if the 62 richest americans gave way,
most are their wealth,
everyone would live above the poverty
line and you go,
but then there would be a new poverty
line.
So then those people.
At what point do you go,
well,
I'm,
I'm rich enough,
we got enough shit,
but I live above the poverty line
because zuckerberg gave me a bunch of
shit and now I
live in a one bedroom instead of a tent
or a cardboard box.
Well then now you live in a one bedroom
and you see the guy in the two bedroom
and you go fucking dick.
Exactly.
So what's going to happen on the poverty
line again?
Yeah.
You're not going to enjoy your studio
apartment.
Fuck that guy with his fucking two
bedroom.
You asshole.
Poverty line is a statistic.
Just like football as well,
there's a problem with getting shit for
free.
There's always a problem with getting
shipped for free.
That's not a problem.
Now you porn.
I thought it was going to give me a
cease and desist.
Gone.
Right?
It's this,
this,
this.
This is like free samples at the safeway
and you just grabbed the whole fucking
trey and ate them all at once.
You fucking asshole.
Stop with your cocaine and your viagra.
Well don't,
they don't.
I'm,
I don't know if this is true,
but you could tell me don't date like
isn't there like a conflict in the porn
industry with the porn.
People aren't getting paid for those
movies and they put them up for free and
so like people shouldn't be supporting
those sites.
Like there's like a,
there's like a dispute and a debate
almost like a,
the napster daYs when what's his face?
Metallica will get really mad when lars
ulrich fucking it can.
People still hate that guy from that?
I do.
I always swore if I ever saw him in a
show,
I would have him escorted out.
And then one time you were with me in
mill valley,
the other guy got hurt.
That's hetfield or whatever his name.
He was there.
He was there and I said,
I always swerve.
That fucking guy was here and you're
close enough,
but I'm not going to throw you out.
And I just started giving him shit
about.
I was like the first comic on napster.
Like they had a home page where they
feature an artist right before they shut
him down.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
And I was the first comic feature as
when people first started finding my
shit under ground and then they shut it
down because of that fucking lars.
oh.
And they made their bones off of people
bootlegging cassette tapes of them
because they couldn't get radio play
like you're shitting on.
What made you,
you fucking little weasley?
I don't know.
Is he norwegian?
What is he fucking know danish?
Whatever it is,
there's no need disparaging an entire
race of people just because of one man's
actions.
Douglas one male,
he fucked up.
He definitely didn't have good friends.
He definitely didn't have somebody who
would give them some good advice too,
and I'd kill the whole indian race just
for that one crying fucking guy on that
commercial.
Sorry.
That was a stretch.
That one didn't,
but whatever.
Sorry.
Swinging in every one of yours because
this is true ladies and gentlemen,
like when we're,
if we fail,
it's not because we didn't try.
Okay.
Don't get mad.
They still might only.
There's only a 444,000 hours of a joe
rogan podcast.
Yeah.
That other.
How do you do this?
It's not hard.
No,
but I'm saying you put
out like 48 podcasts a week and the new
wrestle guys and then he'd do mma and
then you do the 85 hours of standup.
And then uh,
I have my own kind of crazy.
I got my own sleep.
Are you one of those guys who sleeps two
hours a night?
I sleep good.
I like to sleep solid six,
seven hours a night.
I'm not saying how do you sleep at
night?
I got to get eight.
What do you mean in my life?
Do I have a problem sleeping?
No,
I'm saying what do you have like off
hours?
I want to.
This is my goal in life and have
essentially achieved it.
I want to do what I want to do when I
want to do it within reason,
within moral and ethical obligations,
the law and all that kind of stuff,
but I don't want.
If I decide I want to go to bed at 5:00
in the morning,
I don't want to hear shit from anybody.
Like I don't wanna I don't want anybody
telling me you can't go to bed at 5:00
in the morning.
You can't sleep until two in the
afternoon.
Why not tell me why not?
Why can't I wake up at noon?
Why?
Who the fuck are you?
It's a stupid.
So all my life I've wanted to get to a
place where I could go to bed when I
wanted to go to bed within reason and
wake up whenever I want to wake up.
So then if I decided to get up early,
like because I have to like see my kids
at school,
I decide because I have a boss,
it's because I want to because I want to
get up,
I have an obligation to be with the kids
and I enjoy it and want to hang out with
them.
It's like,
I think that if,
if you got to go in life,
the goal shouldn't be,
be as successful as you can be.
I think the goal,
like it's not a money thing,
the goal is to make it as much like what
shit you would normally do.
Like give her a driven guy.
But my point is the opposite.
You're always driven to do something.
It's the same shit every time I talked
to,
uh,
tell you what,
why don't you just take a vacation and
just go fucking sit on a beach somewhere
because he's always not your,
your positive.
Intel's always negative steak.
I lifted up,
I said,
buy cds.
No good.
Everything.
Steaks.
He makes me sad like that because he's
so brIlliant.
But it's such a nice kid.
I know.
I can't imagine either of you going to a
remote beach and relaxing.
Oh,
I relaxed.
I know how to do that.
Now I learned how to do that.
Give me an example.
I go on vAcations where it's the last
one.
Costa rica went like six months ago with
the family.
Had a great tIme,
did some zip lining.
Fucking hung out.
Fed some monkeys.
Nice.
There was this thing called,
we called it a pika chu,
I forget what it's called.
I think it's called the
something ceto something ceto,
but it looks like a little raccoon,
but they're fucking super team because
they were hanging around this resort and
they're just used to vacationers so they
come right up to you and we were feeding
him grapes and shit.
He got so Comfortable with us.
He took a nap in front of us.
Fucking things lying.
They're lying down with his fucking legs
up in the air.
It was an awesome monkey scReaming at
you,
screaming at you.
Come on over here trying to get food
from you.
Chuck them some fucking oreos.
They opened the oreo up and they.
They eat the white part just like a
little kid.
Whoa.
Well how many oreos you eaten?
Monkey.
So I go on vacation.
So I go on a lot of them.
Actually.
No,
not a lot of time.
You talk about coming to biz be I go,
you'd be so bored here.
we'd do some fun shit.
You know,
we do go,
uh,
get some archery tags for some havalina
isn't go fuck up some havalinas I.
Wow.
I am against hunting.
Not against it.
I personally couldn't do it,
but a heavily.
And I could kill that Motherfucker.
Yeah,
you could do it.
That rotten beasts.
Well,
when you tolD me that dog killed your
neighbor's dog.
Yeah.
Killed the fucKing.
Then they hang around in packs.
I like coyotes.
They're fucking awful demons.
They're little demons.
If they didn't exist,
if they weren't real,
he'd be like,
whoa,
these are cat eating dog eating little
demons.
That just doesn't.
They don't have the courage to go after
a person,
but they would.
if your child was blind or if somebody
like put a baby on the side of a toyota
tundra and just drove a few hundred
bottles and on the road,
I just left that baby there for an hour
and the the those peccaries.
That's what they are.
They're peccaries.
I don't even pigs havoline.
Everything's is a pig.
Is a pig,
is a difference.
Different species.
It's a different animal.
That's that fucking creepy fucker.
That's a peccary.
Peccary.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We get on a pig,
but it's not.
my neighborhood is a three streets and
then hills to the mexican border and I
can tell when a pack I have alina are
coming by.
the dogs barking.
Dogs are barking on that blog now.
They're barking on this block now and I
owe a pack a heavily.
Is trAveling that way.
That's so cool that you live in a place
that has these things.
It's so interesting.
Yeah.
They're like rats and fucking vancouver
behind the rick shot theater.
Always.
Always be branding.
They're like little demons,
man.
Like if they didn't exist,
if they didn't exist,
there was this hairy thing in a movie
that would chase after people's dogs and
tear them apart.
Yeah.
That's where I'm the opposite of ted
nugent.
I would kill that and use none of it,
but they're good.
You can eat them like similar to a pig
and a lot of ways.
The best people in Louisiana eat shit
they find on the road too.
But you can.
You can eat a lot of things.
If you're in shackleton's party,
you can eat your shoe until you can find
seal,
blubber.
You can eat anything.
I think they taste good.
I think heavily is supposed to taste a
lot.
Very pig.
Like,
like wild pig,
like wild boar,
which is good.
I think you have to make it and like
sausages and shit,
but the people like it.
I'm still.
I bought burger king,
you know,
you hit burger king,
burger king,
and I told the uber driver,
I go,
listen,
I tweeted,
I go,
I'm afraid to be early because this is a
weird empty industrial lot that I don't
want to be sitting out in front of cold
and waiting for you to show up and I
don't want to be late because you don't
want to be late.
So,
uh,
but I wanted to eat.
So I told the uber
driver,
oh,
we're going to be early.
So just,
we'll fInd some fast food.
I'll tip you extra.
Does a fucking in and out burger on the
way up here.
Well,
on the exit there's nothing but this
fucking industrial area.
And this is my burger king.
Burger king.
Burger king only exists where nothing
else is available.
So you get off that exit.
There's an industrial park or burger
king because burger king's next to
anything else.
You wouldn't eat anything.
A burger king's next mcdonald's,
you would go with mcdonald's.
Absolutely.
You know why burger king was next to
payless shoes?
I'd go with shoes.
I said that.
I'm surprised that every time I watch
him naked and afraid they don't stumble
into a burger.
King was no other option.
Oh,
oh,
fucking worst.
But I had to because there's nothing
else around.
Mcdonald's broughT the fucking breakfast
menu to all day,
but they didn't bring the mcgriddle
didn't bring the greatest creation.
That pancake thing with sausage and
cheese.
It's the gray one.
Creation they've ever made and what?
You can't have it all day.
They have a limited breakfast menu.
But today on newser,
mcdonald's soaring because they brought
breakfast all day and if you know my
body of work,
one of my biggest beefs ever is no
breakfast after 11 because as comics
were not usually up before 11.
Yeah.
And I like breakfast and it makes no
sense.
I'm not going to do the bit.
The Point is that mcdonald's brought
breakfast all day.
I love them.
Fucking sausage.
Burrito.
love her.
That's a good one.
And thEy're fucking their numbers going
through the roof.
I just can't take a risk because if,
uh,
if I'm,
if I'm hungry,
I,
I look forward to egg muffins.
Yeah.
So bad that I don't want to just a
regular egg mcmuffin.
That's what I want to.
A little circular ham circular for no
apparent reason.
Perfectly circular ham like as if that
even was it related to Breed the pigs
and cylinders say breed them and sewer
tunnels.
They pack them in there,
slice them thin.
I think that actually picker is.
Oh,
but anyway,
I'm addicted to those fucking things.
I love egg mcmuffin.
I love them.
Like if I'm coming home when I'm hungry,
I don't feel guilty about eating eggs
and english muffins.
It's pretty simple and straightforward,
but we'll put a process cheese,
but whatever.
Some you also work out like a
motherfucker.
I have friends in Alaska that would
party so hard that you.
Holly,
how are you in such?
Well,
they partied that hard and then go to
the gym for three hours and lift really
hard.
I don't do the second part.
Yeah,
that's going to
be a problem.
He's going to with this crazy lifestyle.
Everyone's been saying this for fucking
20 years ago is actually you'll.
You'll always have this conversation
with me and we were like,
how many surgeries do you have?
Yeah,
when you're just talking today about the
fucking thing they did to your knee and
putting plates and screws and drill and
shit.
Morphine,
write code.
You had to go through that to get to
morphine and I can go straight to
morphe.
Bad.
Neat.
That was an early one.
That was an early surgery.
I've got a gang of them sense things.
Break,
man.
They do want me to.
I got like three hernias work and I
don't lift anything.
If you get them fixed,
it's so easy.
Eddie bravo got to have them fixed at
the same time.
They just stick these.
They have this webbing they put
underneath the umbilical one fit because
you get it fixed,
but the other two I got the ventral.
Where your abdominal.
What would be your six pack?
And I had one that splits apart.
Not a problem,
but the ventral.
Is that regular?
The inguinal.
That's the groin hernia.
That's the one.
One word is why I don't fix those
catheter.
Oh,
they have to.
When you tickle him,
which would have done,
if I coked up after being dumped,
calling hookers and I'm getting a
dominatrix yes,
but put it on a morphine drip,
one of those ones that I got a little
button with your thumb.
Click,
click,
click.
I'd rAther have a dominate your stupid
fucking solid and go.
You're going to just take this fucking
catheter,
aren't you?
You seem so different than you,
but I would like to do.
Oh,
I can drink a bottle of nyquil and
listen to some david bowie get their
ground control to major tom.
Just let them do their thought.
Their stuff doesn't even involve me.
I'm appearance base.
I'm a parents' space.
I don't have time.
Have time to think about that.
Catheter and catheter is not a part of
me.
How many surgeries have you had?
Not that many.
Honestly.
My nose.
Um,
both my knees.
Your nose?
Yeah.
I had a deviated septum and I also had a
bunch of blood that had pooled up inside
the walls of my nose and become
calcified,
like a cauliflower ear,
like a wrestler's area.
I had that in there too.
They had a carve out some holes and they
had to do something called trim your
turbinates.
Your turbinates are like,
I guess it's like these bumps inside
the,
uh,
the side of your nose and they clean
those and flatten them down.
I broke my nose when I was five.
I fell down a flight of stairs.
Even before martial arts smashed my
nose.
I remember crying and blood and snot and
my nose is always been crooked even
since then.
And then from that time on,
I don't.
Nobody ever says [inaudible] gorgeous
except for the nose,
but it's been broken
by four times,
but nothing compared to some people I
know,
man.
I know dudes who've had dozens of nose
breaks,
at least probably six or seven when I.
When you hear people bitching about
athletes making too much money,
they have a professional athlete.
Will have several surgeries in a season.
Could be.
Yeah.
if your dad's getting a hernia surgery,
you'll fly back from college because you
never know an anesthesia.
Well,
and these guys just have surgery.
That's the big argument for steroids
because the biggest argument for
steroids,
steroids rapidly improve your ability to
recover rapidly improved.
So if these guys get a surgery,
like a kelly's tenant or some shit like
that,
the difference between recovery when you
do steroids and recovery on the notch,
fucking cheyenne difference.
I mean absolutely gigantic difference.
They're not taking this stuff just for
performance.
They're also taking this stuff for
recovery.
It's in my opinion,
I mean done correctly.
Like you should allow all athletes to do
that.
Whether it's martial artists,
whether it's anybody.
The problem is like if you're talking
about like a knee surgery,
the real problem is you can get gains
from that,
that you will be permanent.
There's a certain percentage of those
gains gains meaning you gained speed
explosiveness just from taking these
steroids while your going through
rehabilitation because of surgery.
So it is tricky.
It is tricky because that,
that cheating,
whether it's playing football,
what have you,
that cheating will be permanent.
Like you'll be a different person you
like literally will be more explosive.
Maybe even like only fractionally.
So like maybe a half of one percent or
something,
but it's measurable.
You can measure the,
uh,
the tissues,
they can measure the amount of gains you
keep.
There's been some studies on it.
So it's,
it's,
it's tricky.
How much do you need as we near 50 years
old?
It's a hobby of mine.
I enjoy it.
That's the problem.
I enjoy training like it,
it helps me for me personally,
like we talked about like I do too many
things or I do a lot of different
things.
One of the things that it seems like a
half to do in order to stay even is that
I have to do a lot of physical activity.
If I don't do a lot of physical
activity,
whether it's like anything go,
I go hiking,
I could workout,
I could do something,
but if I don't push my body and drained
some energy out,
then I don't feel my best.
I don't feel,
uh,
you know,
uneven.
I don't feel relaxed enough.
Like I have to drain the battery.
So for me like to keep my sanity and
perspective and clarity,
I have to drain the battery.
That's why I do it.
The best way to do that.
I thought you were gonna.
Say cocktails.
Everybody's got their own way.
A problem is my way.
It's prejudiced against.
People are prejudiced against my way.
My way is the way of the meathead.
You can always find someone who's,
oh fuck.
He brought whiskey.
I thought I should just bring whiskey.
Shit.
Got a lot of Jack Daniels in bitch.
I been drinking jack and coke,
but what I don't like is the koch koch
or red bull or anything like that feels
worse than like if you.
I'd rather do methamphetamine,
which is the worst drug ever.
I talked myself into putting the coconut
so I don't feel like a deviant.
Just drink it straight.
Jack daniels.
That seems like something someone is a
reckless.
Not if you drink it on the rocks and a
proper rocks glass.
The nectar of the gods and they be
tinkle the glass and the new snippet.
Isn't that one an entre cold?
It isn't that like part of a Jack
Daniels commercial.
The nectar of the gods baby.
That was a you're thinking of and one of
the last to go know.
I think it was a commercial for jack.
Daniel was there.
Yeah,
pretty sure.
It was a commercial for Jack Daniels
that featured sinatra talking about Jack
Daniels calling it the nectar of the
gods was during one of his shows in
vegas.
The satins or something.
Well,
yeah.
You know,
they had that rat pack era,
which is one of the most amazing times.
let's say here.
We'll listen to it.
Put your.
Put your headphones on real quick,
and the mandatory at country doesn't
have to know is,
is this the one where he does it?
His jet carried it to foreign lands.
I can't get this whole fucking
commercial codes in the end.
You gotta you gotta fucking try these in
advance on how.
Either way.
The point is no one was tweeting.
Sinatra going don't die on us,
man.
Any better.
Back then they didn't think you were
going to die.
first of all,
they thought cigarettes were made you
healthy,
right?
That's back.
When did you see the,
uh,
you've seen the leonardo dicaprio movie
on
wall street.
Now the one,
the one where he played,
um,
uh,
the fbi guy,
j edgar hooverj,
dot edgar hoover,
the j edgar hooverj,
dot edgar hoover's mom was like talking
about him being sickly and how the
doctor had prescribed him cigarettes and
she'd be smoking cigarettes to become
more robust.
Whoa.
Exactly.
Always wrong.
don't back then they were fucking wrong.
J edgar hoover sadly died when he was
with 35.
No,
he lived a full fucking life to
fortunately,
but still.
Yeah.
So when you keep tweeting me don't die
on us.
I know a live a unhealthy lifestyle as
far as we know,
but I'm enjoying it.
So until you're a fucking doctor who was
prescient better than the doctors who
said j dot edgar hoover's mother,
she'd be more robust.
Smoking cigarettes.
Well,
you're a study in a way.
If I was a scientist or a doctor who's
trying to study people that are healthy
and happy and why I'm.
I would study you because I'd be like,
well,
here's this guy that's doing whatever
the fuck he wants to do.
Smoking.
He was drinking,
but he appears relatively healthy in
comparison to a lot of other people that
are not doing those things but are
working full time,
solace,
thankless jobs,
and they're the same age.
Like if I followed your happiness meter,
like if there's a score card and it was
like a fucking college basketball game
and I could look at the happiness meter,
you'd be a dominating victory in the
nine to five offer over the normal 47
year old doesn't have its downfalls.
I wake up in sheer terror and I wake up.
Even when I'm home,
I go,
I gotta get the fuck outta here and I go
right to delta.com and see what the next
flight and then I chill out and then I
eased back in.
There's,
there's downtimes to this.
I'm not saying,
oh,
I'm happy all the time.
Being a drunk and a chain smoker,
but well we all are freaking.
I mean This is a.
This is like a core tenant of being a
human being.
If you're paying attention,
you're freaking out about your
expiration date.
You're freaking out about the fact that
this is a finite experience.
It's going to end and we don't know when
and we don't know why and we're getting
closer.
We're getting closer every day,
but you know what could have happened
when you were to have to a lot of people
at two.
Could it happened in a car accident when
you were five?
A lot of people in car accidents when
they're,
but guys like you that make me feel like
shit about just sitting and watching
netflix for four straight days,
not getting up other than to piss or get
a snack,
but you enjoy that time.
I do.
I wish I Could just go,
hey,
I'm just me.
Why can't I enjoy?
Why do I have to always think I see
someone who can dance and they go,
I'll never be able to dance.
Why don'T why I don't excel at any of.
Rather than focusing on what I do,
well,
I too much focus on what other people do
that I can't.
That's where obsessive struggle comes
into play.
Doug.
Stan hope because it was tests have
struggle with.
I'm really into when I.
Is that what you call fucking groping
men?
No,
no.
That's my obsessive struggle.
It.
It'll fall in everything.
Everything.
I do groping men.
I shoot 100 hours a day.
Archery,
like I just shoot at targets because I
love practicing.
It's fun.
Okay.
That's a great example.
If I shot 100 arrows a day,
I would be thinking,
why am I not doing more with my life?
Like no matter what you do,
I think I should be doing something.
Other people that I respect are doing
what you do,
and I just,
I can't get comfortable with just doing
what I do.
No matter what it is.
I see someone else who does something I
can't do and go work kid.
Maybe this.
Maybe this will help.
ThiS is an insight.
Here's one thing that's true.
If I have things to do and I don't do
them and I go shoot those arrows,
then I feel like a fucking loser.
That's one weird thing.
I can just see the
fuck on shit.
Fucking bullseyes isn't.
I still feel like a loser.
It's like that took me until I was in my
forties to realize that I can't have
anything like the price you pay for
fucking off on something.
The price you pay in mental mortgage is
never worth it.
It's just not worth it.
If I have shit that I have to get done,
I have to get it done Because if I don't
get it done,
it's gonna fucking haunting me.
but what is get it done and what is
within reason and that's what I had to
like hit my forties far.
Realize there is a diminishing return.
What is.
Well it's,
it's,
it's like have to get done.
Yeah,
you have to take care of your shit.
But no,
but,
but other shit like exercise.
Because if I don't exercise I do fucking
freak out because of my body's just so
used to it.
It's been doing it for so many years.
So if I don't do some form of rigorous
exercise,
my body's like,
come on bitch,
what are you gonna make us just sit
around on the stand that.
But we all have different standards or
or or perceptions of what we have to do.
Where do you go,
what do I really have to do?
I would consistently obsessively make
lists of shit I have to do and then I
would find one from a year,
six months ago that I lost and made a
new list and I,
I didn't have to do any of that shit.
I think I have to do shit.
That's definitely true.
You definitely don't have to do
anything.
You just have to survive,
right?
Definitely.
But if you want to try to achieve
something,
like if you want to try,
if you have a netflix special that
you're going to film in six months and
you decide I am going to piece together
a perspective and I'm going to try to
get this material,
I'm going to try to take it on the road,
but I'm going to need to have some life
experiences.
So I'm going to need to go to the museum
of creationism.
It's in Kentucky.
I'm going to go there.
I want to fucking sit down.
I'm talk to the people I'm going to.
I'm going to get us some information if
you,
if you have some shit that you Want to
do,
then you have some shit that you need to
do in order to accomplish the thing that
you want to do.
That's real,
but it's only on your choice,
but once that's when it's at its best
and that's the beautiful thing about
what you're doing,
what I'm been able to do and what it's a
matter of that are listening to this
that are self employed or they're
artists or that are trying to do that.
That's the ultimate goal is to do what
you're doing.
It's decipher between what you have to
do for you versus what you think you
have to do for other people or to live
up to the fans or to whatever.
What do,
what do I actually have to do versus
what I think I'm supposed to do and
that's what I can't get rid of,
so I always think I'm supposed to do so
I have to.
Well,
here's the key.
Here's one key that I've found.
This is just my personal perspective.
Kettle pay.
No,
no,
no.
Don't get an assistant when you get an
assistant,
you're just putting a bandaid on a
problem.
The problem is your life has gotten too
complicated.
For one person I have now.
That's who said,
yeah,
you guys have a partnership.
This is a completely different
experience.
You know,
I don't have an assistant.
I don't know.
Never.
I won't do it.
That's my one.
I won't have anybody who takes phone.
Makes phone calls where if you ever got
a phone call from someone,
hold for bud,
please.
I friend bud would do that.
I would fucking.
I'd call his goddamn cell phone and this
woman would go bud cell phone.
I'm like,
but you're not that much of a big shot.
You fuck you goddamn cell phone.
It ain't that hard.
Guaranteed.
Tom cruise.
He answers his own fucking cell phone is
a few people that just.
They have someone who does everything
for them and they essentially,
they become like mommy and then it
allows you to focus entirely on your
task at hand,
which is to feed this machine.
You've created an employee's and fucking
hairdressers and there are all these
different people that follow you that
you have to carry around with you and
you're like,
you become like an ecosystem.
Don't do that.
No assistance.
As soon as you need another person to
figure out fucking where you're going
and what you're doing and show you what
your calendar is,
you've fucked up.
You got too crazy.
You stay.
Stay low key because you're going to
absorb that assistance.
Problems too.
You can absorb that assistance.
Fucking pill thing.
Fucking all sorts of issues.
Taxes,
they'd never paid their taxes.
You're gonna.
Take those fuckers in,
man.
They're going to be like straight dogs.
You're gonna.
Have real problems or a great friendship
and a wonderful relationship.
Just got to be lucky.
So you said that was the first thing.
I don't have any fucking assistance,
man.
That's number one.
Don't do shit you don't want to do when
you don't have to do it anymore.
That's another one.
A lot of times people get famous and
they get,
they get successful and they get wealthy
and then they start thinking,
I just got a full group is going,
we need to do movies,
man.
We're going to do.
We're going to do our own truck.
You know what?
Don't do that.
Go back to when you and I were 21.
What you started when you were like 24.
I was 21,
but essentially we're in our early
twenties.
What did we want to do?
We wanted to fucking make a living
telling jokes.
Ever sing karaoke,
get postseason karaoke,
karaoke,
but comedy was a thing.
I could go up and sign on a list and
then try to get.
Because that's the embryonic stage,
but once you became a full multicell
organism,
when he became an actual like guys
trying to put together an act,
what was the ultimate goal?
I just wanted to do it.
I wanted to be able to do it.
Well.
I wanted to be.
He didn't want to have a day job.
Well,
yeah,
you want to be a pro comic.
Right?
That was a long time.
I spent three years of just going,
I can't believe I'm driving to Montana,
18 hours to get free cheese cubes at a
happy hour and 125 bucks.
Exactly.
I it.
Yeah.
I did a gig with this kid named scott
peppa.
Carry on a place called block island.
We stayed in a fucking storage house
where they stored canned goods.
They had cans.
Is an island you had to go to.
The people were so drunk they were
barely.
The audience is filmed.
There was no comedy to be had.
I never even got on stage.
They canceled the show.
When he got on stage,
he got on stage.
He told 10 minutes of jokes.
If we can cut the mic off.
It was over.
It was a disastrous,
horrific fucking set.
Heavy quantitative funds since probably
not.
It was a good time.
He used to have another gig called the
amount of points it in was a madam
[inaudible],
Massachusetts.
It was just fucking.
It was like a hotel and then downstairs
there was like this lobby that
inexplicably had one of the best comedy
rooms in all of Massachusetts.
It was amazing.
Guys like teddy bears,
xuan,
lenny clarke.
They would headline down there,
don gavIn,
they would headline down there and I
worked there at gang of times with the
same dude.
So like I assumed that this gig was
going to be like his other gig,
which was amazing,
but it was a new gig,
so we got a boat.
We took off some fucking stupid island
in the middle of nowhere where these
people were just drinking himself to
death.
His.
They were monsters.
They were just drunk,
bloated monsters.
Who's this woman?
She looked like don burris with a dress
and a giant red winston churchill like
gin almost got her up arrows guide last
night,
but go ahead.
She's wortH it.
She was just screaming at this guy who
was on stage.
I'll never forget her.
I glorified the early days when I was in
them too.
I look back at some shit and go out.
It was probably worse,
but most of the time I go,
I can't believe I'm doing this in the
moment.
I like having so much fun fucking the
ugliest strippers in the world and just
happy.
But that was before people had
expectations and as soon as I got what?
Whatever the level of popular I am.
Yeah.
There's a people who expect something
and like,
ah,
fuck god damn it.
I have to work.
Can't just go up onstage and eat a plate
of nachos and tell everyone to go fuck
themselves.
They paid good money.
Now the transition has come full circle.
You ocd because I just drank straight
off.
My heartbeat is only on my dick.
That's the ocd.
Is it?
What does that.
If I did a picture and phobic,
If I was to be letting dude sweat my
mouth,
eight
susan sweater to my eyeballs,
I guess sweat and my ears.
Oh,
it couldn't be hand sanitizer.
Guy and wrestled dudes in [inaudible].
60 nine position.
Well,
not only that,
but I'll do a 3000 seat show and I'll go
outside and take pictures of everybody
shake.
I'll say,
jesus,
I remember the time you brought me to a
ufc in vegas.
The only time I've seen it live and you
walked through the crowd
as they're all lined up to get into this
monster agro fucking
and just everyone's just glommed,
joel.
We get a picture.
You can't get a picture with 3000
fucking people that are in line.
yeah,
you can't do that,
but you just walked through like you're
fucking moses part and sees a cat.
okay.
I gotta go gotta go.
I have three people when I'm trying to
rush out and I'm like,
god,
I'm such a fucking dick.
Like I,
I try to run out the back door like
hedberg used to do.
Hedberg was legendary on a one nighter
with 100 people not asking for
autographs because he's not famous,
but he couldn't even deal with people
tell,
giving him feedback.
He just run out the back door.
It's,
it's definitely an issue if you really
are worried about that.
If you're thinking about feedback or if
you just were worried about interacting
with these people,
worth is is it's a weighted
conversation,
you know,
like they like you and you don't know
them,
so it's weighted and the problem with
weighted conversations,
the big one is that those can become
intoxicating and you could only want to
have a weighted conversation.
You only want to have conversations with
people who adore you and you can't.
Those are,
those are terrible choices.
Like that's a,
that's a reality that only exists for
very few people and it's not in our
code.
We don't understand how to handle that.
Especially when it comes to you for no
reasons.
Like you're a child actor on a
television show and you've never known
anything else.
You know,
like that's an impossible mathematical
equation to ask some little kid to grow
up in.
You are going to grow up and you're
gonna have requirements on you that no
human being is going to be able to as
rate with no one's gonna understand,
you're essentially a prince.
You know you're born and you're five
years old.
You're on a tv show and the world
screams whenever they see you on
televIsion.
It doesn't make any sense.
I didn't see the movie,
but I get cut out of it.
But,
uh,
I saw a trailer,
the chris rock movie.
I take five,
take five.
And uh,
he uh,
I believe in the trailer.
He says that's a problem with being a
celebrity is you can only complain to
other celebrities.
Will there's loss using that level.
Like I think that's his line in that
movie.
I didn't watch it because I got cut out
of it.
He's so famous we can't be friends with
him.
Do you know what I mean?
like we're not famous enough to be
friends with.
I say hi.
Go.
Hey.
What's up dude?
Get the fuck away from him.
He's too famous,
you know,
like every time dave chappelle,
I hang out.
I can't even believe we're talking like
he was at my 30th surprise birthday
party really?
Which was.
Where was that dave chappelle?
Was it far fOllow or something?
He's the best I sweat date as before I
met you probably as dating christine.
We were third year 48,
48 a before me.
Okay.
You're older than me.
You're old elderly man.
I'm your elder.
I'm a march or february.
so if I come to the airport I expect you
to be there for the sign.
Says elder elder,
rogan elder.
We'll make our own friars club and
you're going to have to get me in.
But if we were um,
we were both 30 and la at the same time
that you had to be in la because that
was 97.
Were you in la?
In [inaudible]?
90 seven.
Far follow?
Yeah.
Christine hodge
was around then during the book when I
met you because I met you when my mother
was on stage at the union.
Yes.
And someone said,
joe rogan wants to meet you.
[inaudible] you heard you at the same
kind of comedy and my mother was onstage
and you came in and I try to drag you
out so you wouldn't have to see.
That's the way I think joey diaz
might've been the instigator.
I think joey dee is my nigga.
You got fuck with me.
He's one of us is one of us is a fucking
soldier because when that was,
when diaz was trying to figure out how
to be dheas dheas between 96 and 98 was
in his like hatching phase and then he
burst out of his egg and became joey d
as in [inaudible] 99 and I'll never met.
I'll never forget it because I take them
on the road with me and all of a sudden
I couldn't follow him like around
[inaudible] 98.
I couldn't follow him.
I was like,
follow that guy.
Oh my god.
We were in west orange,
New Jersey.
The same place where the guy bought a
for the comedian.
He bought a bunch of fucking nyquil
bottles that I was talking about.
Yeah,
same place.
Uh,
I brought in joey and this is also the
same place where joey notoriously would
just,
he was a wild man.
He just disappeared.
Shit would go wrong or right.
You know,
he'd have a fucking,
a big bag of coke and some crazy girl
and it'd be holed up and he never make
it to a show.
So I didn't want to not use joey
anymore,
so I started bringing ari on the road
with me,
other guys in the room with me as well.
So joey didn't show up.
At least I had like one opening.
I got booked at a uncle funnies in
davie,
Florida with otto and george because he
had such a reputation of not showing up
for shows because he was a crack addict.
That's a build it as a triple x show.
So they would go headlong in case he
went on a crack binge.
I could cover the time because we're
both of an ilk of triple x.
You will be for.
You'd fit right in there.
Well,
back then I could do.
I was just all dick jokes.
It's triple x.
I'm not on youporn.
I did a bunch of jersey shore gaze with
auto and george otto is awesome.
He's a who was such a,
like a weird soft spoken.
Almost like a guy who he looked like old
school,
like a vaudevillian times.
He had like this,
like affection for those days that we
used to do these prom shows and a danger
fields.
And one of the things that shows what I
did,
I did,
and I'm
sure your listeners know,
auto and george,
you have to,
if you're a fan of comedy,
he's.
I'll go out and say this.
He's the greatest puppet act of all
time,
right?
He.
Well,
he's the only puppet acted a comic would
appreciate.
Well this is.
He stunk at ventriloquism.
His jokes were so awfully and he never
changed them.
And you never cared.
My dad,
this is my favorite,
but don is such a whore.
Her pussy has a draw string,
like a laundry bag.
I watched him in Florida that time.
He showed up.
He had some fucking class.
He had a.
And I would go to him into doing it even
though those,
a partial audience that was black.
Don't you hate black guys with tattoos?
You're doing a great impression by the
way.
I don't know.
It sounds just like george.
Hey brother.
Look at my deck to look up my dad too.
I can't see a tattoo.
You should've done it in white out.
You filthy circus ape.
I've walked out of the room on that one
when there are black people in the odd.
It's
filthy circus ape.
He had some fucking relentlessly brutal
shows.
That was the puppet talking for the
record.
The pocket got stabbed.
Yeah.
I heard a danger fields in New York.
I always thought that was a a urban
legend,
but he confirmed.
He told me about it.
He told me his mouth to my ears.
He told me his fucking stabbed.
He told me the one of the most fucked up
I've ever been and I only remember
because there was coke involved and then
you remember,
you remember?
Oh yeah.
It makes you alert and going,
I shouldn't be able to drink this much,
but it was a alpha brain.
Me and ottawa and george.
It was 2005 and montreal and it was me
and auto and george and Dylan Moran.
Oh yeah.
In a fucking hotel room at the montreal
comedy feStival and I thought,
I'm going to die.
I'm definitely going to die and the
other people are going to die before me.
Jesus fucking Dylan Moran falling asleep
with a lit cigarette,
waiting for more cocktail to be brought
up to the room.
I was at the fucking gas station in
hollywood right next to the laugh
factory for the night driving home and I
never tried.
I tried to navigate gays and gentlemen,
if you're ever near the laugh factory
and you need gas,
we're going to stop and do a commercial
break.
Go to the.
Sorry.
This fucking guy walks up to me and he's
cracked out of his head.
there's something wrong,
something wrong.
He's asking a bunch of weird fucking
questions.
he's real speedy and fuck.
And he's smoking.
When I went to pump gas,
someone had done some fucking sneaky
trick where,
um,
you know,
you press,
like,
what gauge do you want?
You press the button,
you pull the thing out.
They had left it already pulled back aNd
locked in place some spraying,
spraying gasoline.
So I let it go.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
And I,
you know,
I undo the little thing that keeps it on
and there.
But there's gas all over the floor.
And then I started pumping gas in my car
and this guy walks up with a cigarette.
Oh no,
he's got a cigarette just a few feet
from this gas on the ground.
And if the guy decided just throw a
cigarette on the ground.
I mean,
we're literally depending upon the
choices of a fucking moron to not have
my car blow up me die.
I'm literally thinking right now I might
have to sprint out of this position
because have you ever seen what happens
to people when they get in those,
those like they say that you shouldn't
even have a cell phone out.
IT's there's,
there's potential for a cell phone to
have a spark and that spark ignites the
fumes.
That fuel ignites the gas.
And people have died like that.
It's very rare,
but it's one of those,
the right amount of humidity in the air,
the right amount of static electricity.
Weird shit can happen.
This fucking guY's just standing there
with a cigarette and he goes,
it's a nice car man.
Which get it.
I got it from a car store
and then the guy in the fucking
loudspeakers going,
sir,
will you step away from the pumps?
You're smoking a cigarette while you're
while you're standing in the pumps.
So this guY is angry now because they're
suggesting that he shouldn't be near the
pump.
So then he holds his hand up over where
the gases real touch and go,
man,
it's real touch and go and I'm like,
I am not going to fucking burn to death
for some moron and I'm trying to figure
out what I'm going to do.
like what am I doing?
Do what do I do?
Do I jump out of the way or do I just
charge at this guy?
like there's one of two things.
Is gonna happen.
Either I'm going to jump out of the way
and he's going to light this whole
fucking place on fire and I might get to
the road.
I might get to laurel canyon before the
fucking gigantic explosion and all these
fucking houses go up in flames and
that's how it happens.
One asshole,
one stupid fucking asshole looking at
me.
I didn't finger you when you were six.
I don't have any idea what happened to
you that got you to this position,
but here you are fucked up on something
looking at me and you're holding a
cigarette over where the gasoline
spilled on the ground because the guy in
the fucking speaker booth has chosen to
to pick on you.
You got real weIrd man.
It's weird.
When you said finger you when you were
six,
because you're obviously doing a black
guy.
Not when you.
Some black guy.
oh,
well I thought it was a black.
When you said finger you when you were
six,
I thought you meant point you out of a
lineup.
That's how racist I am.
There was something wrong with this
dude.
There was a bunch of.
It was probably a bunch of things wrong
with them.
I think there's probably drugs and it's
probably something else.
It was stupid and drugs together,
but there was definitely some drugs
because when,
you know,
when he was talking to me,
it's just.
It was just like,
there was a weird.
It was like a fucking scary dog.
A scary dog.
Like a dog that would just wasn't like,
ah,
what's his fucking dog?
Get out of here.
I have irrational fears of things
blowing up,
including balloons.
I left a perkins once because there was
a girl doing balloon animals on a sunday
morning for kids and just stuff popping
and blowing up.
creeps me out.
I get past that,
but it's just good.
Whereas camps,
so they just wake you up to a fucking
bunch of balloons,
blowing up the fucking gas tank.
Bb guns out on p cIgarettes is have
fucking sponsor.
I didn't quite turned down yet,
but I told shaylee do research because
I've read like five or six stories about
people having e-cigarettes blow up and
shatter their entire fucking teeth and
jaw out.
There's one that's a guy got paralyzed.
It blew his fucking spine sideways.
Oh,
you only have to read a couple of those
stories where you go,
no,
I'll die of cancer.
One of the craziest ones.
I got front end.
They want to do an uber for babysitters.
I'm like,
bitch,
are you out of your fucking mind?
you think you're going to just have like
a.
You go,
oh,
do you someone wants my loved one.
Someone watched my child who can't even
tell me what happened to him.
Come on over.
Strange person.
Why?
I've shown uber driver like an uber for
like a database is really clear that
this has nothing to do with uber.
This is like the concept that uber uses.
It's I need a driver.
Take me somewhere right now.
Right?
Okay.
I need a babysitter to watch my kid
right now.
Get the fuck outta here.
You gotta be out of your mind,
man.
I was like,
they started describing it.
Tobacco.
No,
no.
I'm not going to be a part of your
shitty decision making.
Like even if it works out a thousand
times.
How old were your kids were seven and
five.
The youngest one was crazy.
Weird people,
which is like you're driving home from a
gig,
I'm assuming at the comedy store and you
pull into that gas station here like the
doors in the background on the stone and
it's the.
I find this.
It's like the majestY of life.
Until that moment,
you didn't think your life was going to
be in peril that night.
True.
You were just suddenly in that moment
just trying to get some gas.
Yeah.
That's the random beat of life,
man.
It's like that's what I do all the time.
I drive an hour and 45 minutes from
brisbane to the airport and every car
that comes past me the other way I.
I wait in case they're drunk,
are they going to swerve into me?
Douglas?
That's called being intelligent.
I'm not afraid of death.
I just want to avoid it.
Well,
you just don't want to die because an
assholes doing fucking truck or math.
He decided to start
beating off all over his fucking
steering wheel and he can't hold onto
the thing when he hits a possum and his
things all slippery like lube and he
fucking goes flying into your lane and
hit your 2013 suburban and turning it
into hamburger time until I'm drinking
and then I don't give a fuck exactly
what.
That's why I drink is beautiful because
what drinking does is it limits
inhibitions.
That blows them away.
It takes them away.
It brings you to a place where you don't
care anymore.
You'Re like,
I can enjoy this moment.
There's.
There's some fucking magic shit in that.
The the whole key to whether it's
drinking or smoking weed or doing
mushrooms are doing nothing or
exercising.
It's like this harmonious balance.
Like there's a path.
Yes,
you tweeted this.
It's from your book.
Give a shit that strippers posts rampage
alcohol cannot.
Yeah.
This is from brian's book.
Alcohol cannot cure every problem in
life,
but if we removed the problems that it
can cure than the path is clear.
Brilliant.
Thank you.
Pass that Jack Daniels and a tale of
adventure.
My novel that's available on the amazon
is clear.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's true.
I have a distrust for people that can't
drink.
Yes.
I'm not saying that drinking is the end
all be all,
but it's also an option and as soon as
it's not an option for people.
There's two.
There's two reasons why it's not an
option.
It's either genetic,
which I completely understand because I
know people that just fucking have that
wacky gene they just had.
They turn it into a sharp eyed fucking.
I've seen I.
I dated a girl once at the fucking
union,
by the way,
at the union.
She was so nice.
I met her.
She was so sweet.
She was from out of town.
She was in.
She was like,
she didn't have anything to do with show
business.
She was completely normal.
We went out one night,
we had a nice dinner together.
I'm like,
wow,
I think this girl is going to be my
girlfriend.
I was convinced.
I was like,
she's really cool.
Like she's friendly and she's nice to
waiters,
so all the things that I like,
she's kind week.
The next day I go because there's a
comedy show.
I mean maybe the next day,
next day or see or whatever.
Whenever I see her again and she's
Fucking hammered before I get there and
she shark guide,
she's gone and she breaks a glass like
this just like.
And she just starts talking shit about
something.
I'm like,
oh,
oh well what a fucking won 18.
We fuck really quick and then I'm going
to drop you off.
She might as well have been a small,
hairy,
sweaty dude with shit smeared over him,
but will look like one of those fucking
things that those old plaster guys do.
When the the,
the wall papering,
she might've been covered in shit.
She,
she might as well have been under a
peccary.
The whole thing was there's no way I was
gone.
Like my,
my survival instincts were like slamming
on the brakes.
I was like,
what the fuck,
dude,
you came that close to this being your
girlfriend.
She's breaking glasses and looking at
you like a fucking zombie.
I'm like,
jesus christ.
I went from one to the other one.
One to like,
wow,
what a.
Like a friendly,
nice person.
That'll make me feel really good when
I'm around her.
We're going to have some fun together
next time.
Shatter fucking.
I'm taking her stabbing,
valets and the neck with a beer bottle
and falling face.
First shipping on the curb.
Picture three years in.
one of those
was there for that,
but at her best she was.
She was beautiful.
She was an awesome person on the best.
That's,
that's,
that's the most magical thing about
people is that they're not like the
idea,
like this is why I hate when people
start to shame people or attack people
on twitter and go after people because
you cannot be defined by moments.
You're defined by the culmination of
your life's experiences and your
interactions and as soon as you find
someone who's trying to,
like I just label someone or lock
someone into one partIcular moment,
you're finding someone who's just trying
to avoid all the flaws they have in
their self when no one's perfect,
none of us are.
And the,
the Idea that you can lock a quote down
and put it doug stand hope said that he
thinks that fucking,
you know,
whatever.
This guy should get aids because there's
jokes suck.
You know,
like if I was trying to describe Chad
shank,
oh yeah,
the friend I'm staying with while I'm in
town and everything about them sounds
Chad shank where he used to do this and
that bad things and he can't leave the
house because he's afraid he might hurt
someone really bad or murdered.
Yeah.
You were telling me the other day.
Yeah,
he's the most beautiful human being in
the world,
but to try to explain him based on his
own like biography exactly is fucking
fantastic.
There's a lot of people like that.
There's a lot of people like that,
so he's going to be the king,
but he understands his own insanity and
learns how to work around it and there's
this flashes of awesomeness to come out
of people like that,
you know,
there's flashes of awesomeness that come
out of unconventional thinkers,
unconventional people or people that for
whatever reason,
you know,
the pressure came from a different
direction and created some fucking weird
kind of like personality diamond,
you know.
And That's diaz diaz is the epitome of
some weird personality diamond.
And I'm not even just talking to joey
like nick diaz and nate diaz,
the mma fighters from the ufc.
There's a lot of spanish people
start scarface.
Fuck you.
Fuck Frank Diaz.
Brothers.
Yeah.
If you just read joey diaz is fucking
rap sheet,
you go.
That's not a good rap sheet is not that
extensive.
He got away with a lot more really.
Then he got in trouble for.
The point is if you,
if you explained all the things that
joey diaz it wrong,
you'd never appreciate joey d exactly.
Like if people in my community,
okay.
I live in a nice community of white
people with babies.
If people in my community,
they said,
well,
who's,
what kind of people do you associate
with?
Well,
one of my best friends went to jail for
armed kidnapping.
There was a guy that had coke and he
wanted to get the coke from the guy,
so he tied him up and he threatened him
with a machine gun,
but he's pretty awesome.
Fucking chris.
Christa,
I won't say her last name,
but christa,
like I'm like,
I'm staying at this guy's house.
I'm like,
sure.
She just got out of prison.
So girl that went to prison for two
years because she had fucking a lot of
weed in her car and got busted in like a
weird county in Illinois.
You know those documentaries,
they thrive on busting people.
Sure.
Hey,
do you mind if I bring my ex felon
friendly?
Is that a.
Is it okay?
I know I'm staying at your house where
people get scared.
What are you gonna do?
Are you going to.
Your friend's going to come over with
going to steal my checkbook.
Douglas.
Exactly.
Can you vouch for this,
this girl or this joey diaz character?
Exactly.
But the thing is like at least joey diaz
has.
Well,
they both,
I'm sure have talents,
but joey diaz has a very marketable
talent.
Like he goes onstage and kills and you
forgive him for everything.
When Julie Diaz goes on stage and
crushes you go,
I don't care what he did,
I don't care what he did.
Come on over.
Come on,
let's party.
That's,
I mean,
that is the reason why,
like in the late nineties,
I brought an extra eye opener.
It was only because of joey because I
just realized that that's what started
that conversation was joey diaz one time
the lake shore theater.
I booked him in the headline and uh,
he just,
at the last minute hours before it calls
up the book or it says I can get some
shit going on.
He's like,
well,
you're,
you're going on in a few hours.
He goes,
shit happens.
My favorite idea store is I'm in jersey.
I'm working at rascals and this is.
This is before I decided to start
bringing the second opening act and it's
the reason why first time he just
doesn't show up.
He says he didn't know.
I didn't know.
I didn't know the god and talk to me.
I wasn't sure if it was real and then
the next night,
so they had to get some local guy.
Look.
Guy shows up like literally the show
starts 40 minutes late.
The whole thing's a disaster.
Look,
guy does well.
We salvage the show,
right?
Second night,
an hour before the show,
I finally get a job.
He had a pager back then.
If you lost that pager,
that was two years ago.
The second night he called,
I get 'em on the phone and he goes,
I'm not gonna lie dog.
I never left.
Vegas is a fucking hour before this
show.
It needs.
He wasn't even New Jersey
and I had to make a decision.
I'm like,
well,
I'm definitely not going to not work
with them,
so I need to get another opening act.
I need to give us more money.
The problem with so many comics,
and I'd say 90 percent of my friends is
there,
great comics when they're there and
they're on,
but they're fuck ups.
We tried to do that tour.
The in bookable is like 10 years ago or
something.
That's the point is they're all funny,
but they're fuck ups.
oh,
I'm 41 years old and how do you rent a
car?
Lpa.
This is so fun.
Well,
this you can't,
you can't like completely hold their
hand,
take them to the dance,
but once they're at the dance that you
can tell them where the good music is.
Unless after the dance they start biting
people.
Yeah.
This is all sorts of levels of fucked up
and you got to find that.
like you,
you and I both have a functional level
of fucked up.
Like one of the things that you and I,
I think we,
we like very early on,
I think we both realized we're fucked up
in very different ways,
but we're both channels were functional
and we're both nice guys.
Like that'S one of the things like when
we worked with a man show were nice guy.
A lot of people forget that's the most
important part.
It's one of the most important things
you see fucking guys that you thought
didn't you retire when I started comedy
while they're still working there
because they're nice guys and they're
friends with the owner even though they
suck.
Yeah.
Nice guy actually gets you further than
it should get you it.
Well,
It's also the,
there's that,
but there's also,
it's the right thing to do because it
made you and I both remember when we
were scared and when we first started
and like I know that you are really good
with young up and coming acts.
you're.
The reason I found out about brendan
walsh who I think is hilarious because I
saw you with him in la and that's how I
found out about them.
And that's like,
to me,
there's this certain people like if joey
says,
this guy's funny,
he's funny,
you know,
if already says someone's funny,
they're funny.
If you say someone's,
if you're taking brendan walsh on the
road with you,
I'm like,
well brendon walsh obviously must be.
He's in,
he's in the group.
You know what I mean?
He's,
he's in the network.
He said,
a lot of guys think because they're
funny,
you taking them under their wing is all
they ever have to do.
And you go,
all right,
you haven't written a joke and four
years,
that's a problem.
Yet a fucking.
I've had a few of those guys.
I had to cut them loose.
But then there's guys like ari that I.
Hari is at an.
All the guys ever took on the road with
me.
He listened more than any of them.
He would like you,
you would,
you would say something to him instead
of him getting upset and saying like,
yo,
but I could've done this.
He would go,
oh
yeah.
I keep seeing it.
Like one of the only guys like donkin
kinda too.
But joey and I had a very different
relationship.
Joey's,
my relationship with joe.
He has always been praise and love and
friendship and both ways.
And he's just always been so funny.
Like ever since he figured it out,
I,
I don't,
I can't tell him what to do,
you know,
I just love them and give them hugs,
and he's kind of the same way with me.
We just.
But ari,
when I met art,
he was the fucking,
he was a door guy,
the store.
I started taking them on the road with
me and giving them money to do gigs.
Like the first time I took him as a,
I think the first gig he ever did with
me was the comedy works in denver and
Mike Young,
she used to go on the road with me and
uh,
I called my guns back like the early
days.
I had a flip phone and I called Mike
Young ago.
Mike young.
I go because Mike Young had to cancel
for a wedding or something,
you know?
And I called him uncle Mike Young,
you fucked up.
I go,
listen to shift fear killing.
I held the phone out the fucking
audience.
I go,
you fucked up son and shit,
and I told laurie about it and he was
fucking crying,
but Mike Young was always there.
He was.
The only reason why he was there was
because joe,
he couldn't come to denver because he
had a restraining order.
Joey and his trading order with the club
that he literally could not go in the
club.
It wasn't a legally allowed to go in the
He also wants to leave the state.
No,
that was seattle.
I couldn't take them to seattle.
I had to break new guys to seattle kits.
He had some fucking domestic violence
charge or wasn't happened in.
Yes,
but it wasn't domestic violence in
seattle.
It was like something happened.
It wasn't domestic violence.
It was some,
some form of violence in seattle that
was unrelated to his machine gun
kidnapping.
A drug dealer shot.
Fucking take totally different crew at a
seattle crew,
which consisted of duncan nri.
That's how doug had gotten the mix.
Seattle duck is the best as he's great.
He drives a mercedes now.
Oh,
he's got some crazy amg,
but I'll ask it off the air,
but another thing,
another thing.
Oh,
have you used.
Have you ever had to like read the riot
act to any support act?
Like have you ever had to discipline
someone?
Not tell.
So fucking do that again in front of me.
I know
you've been late three nights in a row.
no.
Brian.
Brian likes to find the worst thing when
we're in a green room at an improv and a
waitress comes back to bring us drinks.
Pre show.
Who is the worst comic you've ever had?
the same thing I always ask.
Yeah,
there you go.
I always ask the guy who was driving to
the radio,
the guy who drives you in the morning
obviously.
Who's the biggest dick?
Yeah,
richard.
Jenny came up a lot.
Really,
even though,
like I said,
I was a huge time.
Who comes up the first?
Who?
Eddie griffin.
Well,
he's crazy.
But again,
eddie griffin,
you go back to eddie griffin on um,
what was the fucking hbo def comedy jam?
Eddie griffin on def comedy jam.
He had shorts on and her rushed.
He crushed to the point where I remember
watching him,
he was on hbo and I was like barely an
opening act or maybe like some sort of a
halfassed for gazy middle act.
Right.
And I watched him on hbo and he fucking
destroyed and I remember being so sad
thinking I will never be as good as this
guy,
that I don't have it in me.
There's nothing.
He was bouncing around on stage and he
had power and expression.
He was skinny and wildly like some kind
of fucking jimminy cricket character hop
it on stage.
And he was,
he had so much fucking performance,
like talent in him.
I remember thinking,
man,
I will never be as funny as eddie
griffin.
I'll never forget that
now.
Fuck.
And I did a oh and a,
uh,
when they were ona and a,
and dice came in because they were
scheduled at the same time and dice came
in and immediately
lit up a cigarette and opie goes,
shit,
a dice is going to smoke in the studio.
Like,
like I cAn't tell,
you know?
And there's no personalities like that
anymore in comedy.
The kinisons,
the dices,
there's no,
I'm overwhelming.
I'm a rock and roll star was impossible
to talk to.
He was a complete character,
which I,
uh,
I love.
But I'll tell you this,
the reason why you're not like that is
because you're better than him.
Well,
I know,
but the same sensitivity to the moment
that makes you aware.
I'm not saying I'm
next.
I set it on rogan's podcast.
Better than what the fuck are you and
ari,
I'm going to put you in a spaceship and
shoot you right to the fucking sun.
I need some more hate mail.
But the point is,
tell me one thing you guy that hasn't
said anything the whole night.
Jamie,
tell me one thing,
you know from hicks's boDy of work that
tells you anything personal about him.
There was,
he had opinions.
He didn't have enough time or you,
here's the date.
Anyone,
um,
where did they live according to his
fucking body of work?
What was his day like?
What did he ever fucking do that maybe
I'm a human being.
He had opinions.
He could read a book and then make a
dick joke in the middle of it and then
make the point right.
I'm fucking better than him,
but I'm not as,
as most comics
working today,
but I'm better than fucking headaches.
Well,
I didn't die at 32.
He had a problem with cigarettes.
You apparently don't have a problem with
them.
Um,
I'm way better at.
Cigarettes was a different.
He was at a different age and they'll
breeze through my pancreas will.
If you go back,
you are rude and you're killing my
heroes.
But if you go back to lenny bruce's day,
like if you go to my house,
I have lenny bruce posters.
I have in my where I have a pool table
in my house and above my pool table.
I've lenny bruce at the fillmore.
And then in my office where I write,
I have this lenny bruce performance film
posters,
movie poster.
But I fucking listen to listen.
Bill hicks winked at me in a giant your
in your house after I came out of the
only time I ever did dmt.
I swear to god,
I came out of this thing going,
oh my goodness.
Oh my goodness.
And then I saw there's a bill hicks.
I have a cigarette with the american
flag.
Oh yeah.
It's in the pool room.
That's in the poolroom to whatever room
I was in when I went to go.
I worried about you that night.
I thought I lost you because I got him.
He only dmt and we went fucking,
I think I gave him a way too big a dose
because he was the first guy I've ever
met that foamed at the mouth.
Like,
legitimately he had bubbles.
That's the poster I have in the pool as
the one where he worked at.
Yeah.
But he had bubbles coming out of the
corner of your mouth.
You're a moaning and you're going on.
Um,
uh,
I knew my first cognizant thought was a
or memory is saying,
oh my goodness.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
Well that's what it'll do to you.
That wasn't the improv night was.
No,
no,
no.
That was as.
We'd always a smart move.
The dmt was a smart move.
We were doing the mancho when we came
over to my place to try to write and try
to storm ideas and come up with some new
sketches and just and then deal with the
hand that we'd been dealt because stan
hope and I,
we both,
we had this,
I don't want to name any names,
but there's a bunch of people that sold
us an idea that we could go in and do
something chaotic executives,
executive teams.
They're fucking.
People wanted to get us attached.
If we were attached,
they knew they had some names and they
could take that and they could resell
it,
so that's what they did.
But then once we were working,
once we asked on the set,
they had very different ideas as to what
it would be versus what we had and our
ideas were based on the conversations
that we had that made us agree to do it
in the first place.
Whereas their ideas are based on the old
shows.
So there was a little manipulation,
but that's just part of what the fuck
happened.
So we would go back to my.
We went back to my place one night and I
don't remember whether we decided it was
the end where this was the end of this
show and we had to write these monologue
or whatever bullshit we were already
going through,
like such stupid shit.
Like we had this game show called.
It was called make me hard.
That sort of supposed to be called.
That's what doug's original name for it
was because it was your idea.
Make me laugh.
Was a game show.
That was a where you get a contestant
and there's three comedians if you can
not laugh for how ever many minutes tell
him this.
I have to piss tell her I was waiting
for you to wrap up because I have to
piss.
Keep going.
Make me make me laugh.
Was a game show where a contestant had
to not laugh while three comedians
fucked with them.
So we were doing a spoof called make me
hard where someone tried to not get a
boner during three acts and then we had
a midget fell eating a banana and then
we had a lap dancer.
Very hot.
Okay.
That pulls their dick out at the.
I see.
So and then the guy sitting there and
what we call the [inaudible] box that
measured whether or not he was getting
erect.
That was controlled.
Of course
that was.
Sorry,
forgive me.
Is this the concept or what happened
that the concept happened,
but at the last minute sensors said,
you can't say,
make me hard.
Go with make me stiff.
What's.
Yeah.
It was like,
wait,
you're a transvestite.
Pull her cock out onstage,
but you have to just make sure you're
employable enough by.
I gotta make some change.
Oh,
hard.
That's to adult oriented.
Stiff will go.
You can do stiff and at the last minute
all the fucking props people had to go
make a new sign is fucking ridiculous.
Well,
they were crying.
They were crying like no names,
no names,
no genders crying.
Joey diaz was gonna introduce us.
Okay.
Joey diaz was going to come and tell his
kids he has timberlands on and a fucking
baseball hat on.
He's got a New York mets baseball hat on
and fucking timberland's.
He comes out.
He's like,
you ladies and gentlemen,
let's get this party started.
Welcome to the man show motherfuckers,
and they going to beat this out.
This is what they tell doug and I,
they say,
we're going to let you swear.
We'll beep it out.
We'll show nudity.
We'll blur it out.
If you guys get sued,
it'll be great for the show.
You know,
doug and I got together.
We got drunk and go,
whoa,
what do you want?
Do You want to do this?
They want to do this.
You want to do this?
He goes,
let's fucking do this.
Let's fucking do the.
Let's do.
We're going to do this.
We're going to make the crazy.
Once we got in,
it was a totally different story.
Once the paperwork had been signed,
we were committed to this project.
Then there was the executives,
the executives sort of had control over
the executive producer who had control
over the writer.
Everybody's keeping their job.
There's a bunch of things that doug and
I just didn't anticipate,
so we got to this position where we were
doing something that wasn't what we set
out to do and we didn't.
Didn't feel good about it,
and then there was like a bunch of
arguments and one of them was how the
show would start.
I want every sHow to start with joey
diaz naked running out to the audience
and this woman was crying.
I shit.
Damn.
I set of gender.
Let's this executive.
They don't know he friedman
pitch.
Oh damn you stan.
Hope I love zoe.
She was crying.
Is this really what this man show a
crying?
And I said,
how about this?
I go,
we'll do it both ways.
We'll do it the regular way first and
the second take.
We'll do it with joey,
which was a fucking set up.
I can't believe she agreed to that.
That's so dumb because the second take
is always boring because everybody seen
the first take,
like it's a setup,
but she didn't see a comment.
She was playing checkers.
The whole fucking thing.
It was a setup.
We're doing a better.
Yes.
Yeah.
So joey comes out,
of course,
roars.
Everyone stands up.
Let's get this party started.
Ladies and gentlemen,
mark motherfucking man.
Show hope.
Everybody's standing up like this is the
greatest opening for a show ever.
So I look at them and I go told you.
I know.
It's funny.
It might not be funny to you,
but you don't have a dick.
All right.
You're not a man because this whole idea
of this is supposed to be a major issue
already showed you earlier.
A big fat fucking guy deck crew,
giant balls and an old ladies pantyhose.
They were ridiculous as balls are
comical in their own.
Look at him.
He does not look real.
You'd have to sell me on joining.
He's one of the greatest human beings
ever.
Walked the face of the fire in the
background.
Yes.
Fuck yeah.
Austin,
Texas.
That's back.
Uh,
that place doesn't exist anymore.
That place.
I had a dude pounded on my door asking
me for someone named ed.
He was looking for crack.
It was like a crack house.
Yeah.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Nope.
I'm going to take that back.
That's actually austin,
Texas.
That's not houston.
That's austin,
Texas.
It was Texas.
Now I'm regrouping.
That's in.
That's the place that's down the street
from cap city comedy club.
He's the best.
That's from a blog that I wrote called
happy pills because you still read a
blog.
Not not much anymore.
I keep it in myself.
I write them,
but they become material.
What I found was that I was writing
blogs and then I was taking some of the
ideas out of those blogs.
That's what I was turning them into
bits,
but the problem was people would be
upset though.
Well then this is sucking.
I've saw that it was in your blog and
will go,
okay,
well I have to make a decision here.
Either I keep doing the blogs and the
bits are in the blogs and people don't
mind or people get annoying and they
start complaining that the genesis of
the bits occurred in the box.
Guys,
it was two guys that said that and it
gets in your fucking head.
They don't know this,
but you know better if you think it
through,
but yeah,
initially two guys,
I won't do two shows in a night because
I'm afraid someone will stick around for
the second show and go.
But it's a magic act will shit.
Yeah,
they will.
They will.
That's why I don't do two shows a night.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
you could look at it that way,
you know.
Um,
I've heard it said go take a post.
Did you piss on standing up?
I've heard it said that maybe it's not
bad if someone goes to the first show
and the second show,
a few people in the audience actually
makes you think because those people
were there and you're aware of them.
You have to do it fresh.
You have to figure out a way to put a
new spin on it.
You have to figure out a way to present
it in a way that maybe it'll be exciting
for you and that way will be exciting
for them as well.
So in a way where instead of just
pressing play,
you say,
even though this is something that I've
said multiple times over the course of
the last x amount of months that I've
been working on it,
I'm going to say it in a new and
inspired way because I know these two
people from the first show going to be
here at the second show.
He wOn't tell me if there's people that
have stayed over town because he gets
old party.
No,
no.
I get my head.
I'll try to do completely different
material.
That's not even materials to care for
us.
Yes.
Because two fucking people.
I go,
I,
I've,
I've shows the awkward people their
money back going,
hey,
I saw you in manchester.
I'm going to come see him leads
tomorrow.
I'll give you your money back right now.
Don't do that to me.
I told this dude and manchester,
if you're going to come.
He said,
I'm coming to two shows.
I go,
you got to get really fucked up.
The first show.
The second show is novel.
You can't come to think about my
audience is most of them are drunks.
And they don't remember.
I get emails all the time,
hey,
I hope that thing that specialists
coming up,
because I don't remember I was there,
but I don't remember a thing from it.
Well,
I think that potheads and alcoholics,
shane share that the lack of memory,
and it's this,
this,
this is what's beautiful about alcohol
as well as beautiful about pot is this
desire to somehow or another embrace
this moment.
And with pot it's always the fear of
getting carried away by the new found
ideas of what reality really is.
Whereas with alcohol,
it's the ignorance of those ideas.
The point like,
who fucking cares?
Who cares what we do in shots,
who've going to Mexico,
you know,
that's where it comes in with alcohol.
Whereas his weed,
you know,
you're like,
I know how to get to the roof.
Let's go man.
It's just like,
it's so weird to think that there's just
a few hundred miles.
There's fucking gas and like what does
it magnets or something like,
what's the magnetosphere?
I don't know,
man.
Let me get my phone.
And you're trying to figure out why the
earth.
It doesn't just absorb radiation from
the sun somehow or another.
It's been designed so there's like the
seal.
It's like circular shit that you don't
understand.
The magnetos fear and the honest fear.
It's all fucking filtering gamma
radiation.
That becomes your freak out instead of
the alcoholic freak out,
which is just a number.
Your jack and then I gotta get the fuck
outta here.
I know what we're not going anywhere.
I fucking on uber.
Yeah,
drunk uber.
I think that it would get a newborn vrs.
That's where I'm going.
I don't know what it means.
This means you're going to do some
hollywood type share with sound.
What?
Whoa.
Whoa,
whoa.
What have been the adr multiple times?
What does it mean?
What's during the fear factor days?
It was the worst parts about the job.
Here's a fuckIng cold,
hard,
ugly fact about fear factor.
If you watch it on tv,
especially on a chiller network where
still place like 12 hours a day,
if you have done is on all day long.
Not that it's bad thing,
good thing,
but if you watch it,
a lot of the times when I'm talking,
I'm not really there.
I'm talking in a sound booth somewhere
where I had to watch the replay and like
maybe some shit didn't come across right
because the sound was all fucked up or
sound cut out or something like that.
If you ever watch bar rescue or any dumb
shit reality show you're into,
if they're not showing john taffer
saying,
well get the hell out of my bar.
They're Showing the back of his head.
He never said that.
He said after the fact.
Is that what adr is exactly what I want
to know what it stands for,
like especially on a reality show
dialogue recording,
but jamie's actually an audio engineer
automated dialogue.
Oh,
there you go.
There you go,
bitch.
Brian,
hold guess close to.
I was wrong.
Shut up.
Why is this guy always interrupting?
Why is he like red band always
interrupted with the fuck this guy get a
mellow yellow t shirt.
How dare you?
I bought online.
I don't even know what it was when I
bought it.
Really,
I just thought it was a nice phrase.
Well,
it was a song and it was a drink.
remember the total number,
that donovan song,
but I didn't know.
I didn't know as a drink.
Yeah,
it was a drink,
like a,
like a really shitty mountain dew,
like a mountain dew for people.
Couldn't find mountain that you're
taking.
That's what I'm saying.
A lot of shitty mountain jew shit faced
were
hammered.
Um.
Is that.
Yeah,
definitely.
You're right.
I hope I'm going to get one of those.
I'm going to call one.
Ooh,
come in quite.
That was the song that,
uh,
at bob dylan beat them down with bob
dylan.
Did some.
There's,
there's a film of him like parodying a
donovan on stage in london.
It's inevitable.
There's venus even amongst amazing
musicians.
yeah.
That's a good song.
That song.
How dare you.
Bob dylan.
But he's going nowhere.
He wrote all along the watchtower.
He did.
God damn.
That was good.
That was one of the few songs where I
appreciated equally,
whether it's dylan or hendrix,
you know,
either one of them is good.
They've got their own weird little
little bend on it.
You know,
you don't even give a fuck about music,
do you?
he's knocked down tight.
You like,
look,
if you talk about football,
that's the same way I feel.
I.
I don't even give a Shit about football.
Worst superbowl,
fucking whatever.
You have said some outrageous things
during this podcast.
Doug.
Stan.
Whoa.
This is fucking denver against carolina
stinks.
Why?
Why does it stink?
No one cares about those teams forms and
no one hears todd.
I like peyton manning.
He does funny commercials.
You've got the two most almost can
actually do funny and that's what I love
about him.
Well,
him and tom brady seemed to be designed
to make the perfect person.
If they could just get together.
Girl,
there's two sperm lassoed together,
like one of those high school ropes.
We have to climb in the gym.
If the two sperm intersect the egg and
the exact same time and create a super
personally time,
an athlete can actually pull off even a
little bit of funny where you didn't
expect it.
It's hilarious.
George foreman was hilarious when he was
making his comeback.
Fight a man,
unless he's in bed on a respirator,
I make sure they're off their respirator
for at least eight days before I'll
fight him.
That's a quote from George Foreman.
He was hilarious during his comeback.
IT was so when comedy is unexpected,
it's the best.
Yeah.
Well george former been at a bar where
you're saying some funny shit and they
go,
what do you do for a living?
After everyone had an unknown bar likes
you and then you go,
I'm a standup comedian,
and they go,
oh,
now they're judging everything you say.
If you've had that before.
Yeah,
I drink it.
A lot of unknown bars and you just start
like,
well,
here's my stories.
One of my favorite doug stories is with
fucking boxing match and vegas,
and you were a heckling and hold them
down and fuck his face.
It'll destroy confidence.
This is the.
This is the prelims.
This box listening audience.
You have to understand when you go to
whatever his boxing or ufc,
the undercard no one's there.
They're all out getting drinks and
waiting for the thing that they don't
understand to happen.
That's at the end.
So it's dead silent.
Bingo hall church.
Silence.
So you can heckle and froM the back row.
But joe rogan good a second row,
so it's absolutely quiet and we're in
their heckling.
Let me take your fucking him in the ass.
no,
no.
Let's take it from because I wasn't
heckling at all because douglas doesn't
do marijuana.
Joseph does marijuana.
Douglas does alcohol.
Joseph's freaking out because douglas is
heckling him on your ticket and I'm
fucking laugh.
You're the one who brought me in and so
I'm kind of your responsibility.
Yeah,
try making him come.
That always knocks me out like a light.
Wait till two seconds to go and say you
just got punked.
I don't remember that one was.
There was a five fights in a row with no
one in the arena.
The boxers could hear you.
Well,
no,
no.
He's being too humble here.
He got.
He started getting laughs and that
became a problem.
Became a problem.
It was wonderful.
I think it was holding down and fuck his
face.
That was the one that broke to
waterfall.
Breakfast.
Confidence.
Let me say something about doug stam.
Hope will heckle a boxing.
Like when he starts the right way.
It isn't just dive right into the
holding down and fuck his face.
He's,
he,
he starts with some like light jabs and
then he builds up and it gets more and
more bizarre and then it got to the
whole down and fuck his face.
But when he said hold him down and fuck
his face,
I remember just hear people go,
oh shit.
Dawn came.
He showed up at some dog king should
have.
Remember the don king haeckel,
but don king showed up while you can
still hear of my ankles.
And uh,
uh,
what was the name of his movie?
Whatever in America,
only in America.
Can you,
can you.
I yelled something only in America.
Can you fuck over somebody?
I know you had so many once,
but he was there and could hear every
word.
I said,
well,
you started getting laughs and that's
what had happened.
You started getting like big laughs and
then it became like kind of a weird
standup show.
Oh,
so ridiculous.
It was so much fun.
He's one of the hill.
He was fighting that night and a pepper
of freddie roach was his trainer.
Really?
Yeah.
Freddie roach was in the telemarketing
business with me before he ever got into
parkinson's.
Are boxing,
whatever.
it started out with boxing and then
showed its true form parkinson's.
Him and his brother pepper or you have
both.
They're both punchy as fuck,
but I did tell them marketing with them
in the eighties in vegas.
He's a nice guy,
man.
I did an interview with him a long time
ago for the ufc.
It was probably like four or five years
ago and he's such a nice guy.
Freddie roach.
He,
you know,
he might be hindered by this parkinson's
disease,
which is pretty pretty honest about
that.
It's trauma related,
but he's pretty sharp underneath there,
man.
He's not stupid.
Yeah,
parkinson's is one of those things.
I.
I used to use that as an example of
being drunk.
My motor skills are slow and I'm
slurring and I'm stuttering.
My brain's working and that's what yo
see.
P or fucking whatever,
chris,
crazy legs funds saika denver comic.
He's got whatever it is,
cerebral palsy and guy created this.
He's also a wicked alcoholic.
That doesn't help but just jogging,
like greed gig guys ruined me.
I'm really guarded and that's what being
a drunk is like.
Yeah,
my mind is functioning well,
but the more I drank your Jack Daniels,
the more my mouth go.
Yeah,
man though,
he also make bad choices.
Bad choices.
Cerebral palsy doesn't call hookers in
the middle of the night,
going a bit more than he expected to not
call hookers in the middle of the night.
If you have cerebral palsy,
like at that point,
all bets are off,
right?
No,
I'm saying cerebral palsy.
He doesn't regret having cerebral palsy
in the morning.
Right?
Oh,
I get it.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
He's just drunk when I paid $500 to not
fuck me.
There's a lot of story behind this that
I can't tell on the
lease.
Hold is.
It was a last night,
was a bad night,
but it will save him is on the stove
or robby krieger there.
I don't know who's there.
You know.
One of the things that I enjoy about
you,
doug,
stan hope is that you,
you still seems to be,
at least to me when I listen to your
podcasts especially who's still trying
to have fun.
You're still,
no matter what weirdness comes your way,
he tries like,
like break up fucking chaos,
road travel who are still trying to have
fun,
key word trying.
You shouldn't have to try to have fun.
The same as a relationship.
You shouldn't have to try in a
relationship.
People say,
oh,
relationship is a.
It's really hard.
You have to really try.
Well the no do we try and our
relationship,
we've been friends from fucking 15,
20 years.
I
just try to,
you know,
I'm going to have to like,
let's go to counseling to be friends.
No,
you don't have to.
If it's a good relationship,
you don't have to try.
When I hear people doing the counseling
thing,
I'm like,
oh man,
fuck off.
Well,
you know,
as long as you don't have to keep doing
it,
like the one of the problems that the
counseling is a lot of people that
you've done out.
No,
no,
but I have on my life he had been like a
going into isolation tanks.
That's my own form of counseling.
Pot cookies or any sort of pot edible in
an isolation tank is so much more
intensely introspective than any,
any,
any other person that you don't really
know,
like you know,
you,
you know,
you know you.
So if you,
if you do like some real heavy dose of
edible marijuana in an isolation tank,
you get to look at yourself and like a
really weirdly introspective way.
No,
no,
I think that's one of the things that's
so fun about alcohol because it frees
you from a lot of the nonsense that's
involved and introspective thought with
a finite lifespan,
you know,
because like,
like,
well how much you can figure out pitch.
Yeah,
how much you going to figure out you're
going to die no matter what.
That's the freedom of that.
Alcohol sort of throws your way is the
freedom of realization that sometimes
moments are critically important.
They are sometimes more important in the
future,
the same way you must enjoy the,
uh,
the theater of like smoking pot.
You,
the way you chop up lines,
you don't drink coke,
the ceremony.
Yes.
Chopping up lines and then finding a
straw and doing that.
I love that with alcohol.
Like I carry my own cocktail straws
Because I like a short glass with a
small cocktail straw.
I liked the ceremony and uh,
there's something to that and then I get
drunk and go,
fuck it.
I'm just going to drink off.
Uh,
we know my thoughts are on rogan's
bottle.
Drink it straight to the ceremony.
I have thoughts on that.
Do you ever go to the place where he
grew up in a visit and you have like
this weird feeling like,
ah,
I haven't been to the place where I live
when I was in high school until I was
like 44 or 45 or something like that.
I went back and when I went back for the
first time in all those years,
it was really bizarre.
I was like,
there's like an attachment of ideas that
I have to this place,
you know,
and I think that kind of carries on to
to.
Absolutely.
You know what I mean?
Having to write that book,
memories I have not shut out,
I just don't matter,
but I had to go back to write that book
and I just remembering these things that
happened.
I'm like,
oh,
that's that feeling.
Yeah.
Just when I had her,
when I was doing that dumb run for
president and had to go back to a
fucking high school to talk to people
about it.
It was a short lived,
funny idea that wasn't funny at all.
But walking into a high school,
all that fear was absolutely relevant in
2007.
LIke I was 19,
79.
Right.
I'm terrified of being in a highschool.
Someone's going to beat me up,
someone's going to pick on me was just
right there at the surface.
So yeah,
there's definitely a correlation.
I remember when you were doing the run
for president thing and you realized
early on there's no way you could do
standup.
That one has any money I made from
standup would be a donations to the and
then you have to.
I can't do taxes when I do my taxes,
I just over pay on their behalf because
I suck at math so bad that if you ever
audited me,
you owe me money.
Does that make sense though?
I mean why would I stink at it?
But what?
Why would it.
Why would they be so terrified of people
speaking publicly?
Well,
because that's what it is.
Like what is about your shows?
Like if you,
if you were a dentist and you're running
for president,
I would assume the.
You would still be able to work on
people's teeth.
Yes,
but as a public performer,
if you are going to be some sort of a
political figure,
like you're going to have a voice on a
soap box in front of all these people
with a microphone.
You can't do anything else on a
microphone because it's kinda the same
thing and their eyes.
There's something that's really similar
between someone doing a political
politician act and someone doing a
standup act.
They're almost interchangeable.
They're.
They're essentially admitting that it's
show business.
There's no two drink minimum at a
fucking Donald Trump event.
Should be.
Should it be fucking awesome.
Humanity.
Just wait.
It's the countdown,
so someone screams,
nigger
feeding them.
Drake's just waiting.
Just waiting for someone to fucking pop
the n word views.
Just drunk enough to get a fucking giant
room full of trump supporters drunk
enough people say that.
Oh,
as a comic,
wouldn't it be great if trump got
elected because your dad is so much
material?
Well,
no,
I'd have so much entertainment.
Go material.
you know,
comics who just find a news of the weird
article and just repeated on stage with.
No,
the joke was already written in the news
of the weird article.
You need punchlines.
Trump would be hilarious to me.
I wouldn't use it as material because
it's inherently funny.
Like a news of the weird article.
It didn't make sense.
It is kind of right,
but how.
How much weirder is he than mitt romney?
Because if I have to choose between a
guy who's,
you know,
a part of some weird fucking ideology,
we.
Yeah,
weird ideology or a guy who's just a
super ambitious reality star who also a
billionaire real estate developer.
I'm going with that guy.
Even if he says,
yeah,
he's for entertainment for himself.
Yes,
but maybe not just he doesn't give a
fuck about you or the country,
but maybe he's entertaining.
Maybe a little,
maybe a little.
Remember when barack first get elected
and you thought,
oh,
maybe he's over.
Things will really change in within
minutes.
you go,
nah,
nah dude,
it was black people and white people are
the same.
It's just the amount of money they have
or why it was a.
It was a moment where I think I've kind
of like for the first time I understood
that to be someone that gets into a
position like the president or something
like that.
The idea that that one person makes all
the calls for all the decisions that get
made about all the functions of our
government and education system and,
and then,
and then it is,
you know,
first responders and cops and
firefighters.
There's no way.
There's no way you can pin it on one
guy.
He just can't do it.
No,
it's not.
It's an american one president that has
affected your life that your life
wouldn't have gone that way regardless.
Ronald reagan,
him,
and what happened?
What happened to you?
Ronald reagan fucked up everything for
your life specifically.
I'll say no,
there are people do.
They said some saying kim jong,
il.
Listen,
I'm a fan of narcos.
It's on netflix.
I haven't watched it yet.
Get on it immediately.
You know why I haven't watched it yet
because I think that I have things I
have to do and I don't.
So I,
I'm putting off narcos until I have some
time off from the life I have that
sedentary anyway,
but I have a list.
What is it?
Creating a mentor too drunk to be on
this podcast.
Make or have you gotten there yet?
Oh,
if you have not watched this staircase,
watched that and then watch making a
murderer because making a murder of will
make you very upset for about 24 hours
and then you in hindsight
go,
yay.
Probably did it.
Watch the staircase,
which is a 15 years old where they give
full access to the prosecution as well.
Making a murderer is completely biased.
They're trying to make you think that
guy's innocent.
Then you find out behind the scenes,
oh,
that girl from the auto trader,
he had called several times,
answered the door in a bathrobe once a
use trying to get.
She asked to not have to go there.
The guy he wrote her,
actually,
he did murder.
Sumi
is by the way,
is available on netflix,
but only on disk.
You have to order a staircase.
Giant spoiler alert.
This whitney coming say to a watch.
That was her recommending staircase.
You know what?
I would fuck people on twitter.
I would fuck whitney cummings if I could
just change her act.
You heard it here first.
Her sister is my yoga teacher,
which is very nice.
Yellow.
Let's not get fucking five degrees of
kevin bacon up in this bitch.
Jesus christ.
That was just a call back to an earlier
joke and it's not at your expense.
Riders on the stove.
Get me out of here.
I'm fucking drunk.
I get to go home.
Yeah,
I booked a ticket.
I get a lead time.
What's happening now?
Okay.
All I fucking left.
I came here.
I didn't say which nine,
but I have to leave at nine.
Well,
it can't be pm.
That's a long time from now.
Have no sympathy of as a pm.
I'm shit.
Okay.
We're good.
We've,
we're all right.
Hannigan,
you're in charge of this fucking ship,
right?
I had a question for you.
joe.
You're evolve as a question for you.
Do you use two phrases of the year
phrases or did he come from somewhere?
I would say obsessive struggle and
mental mortgage.
Um,
I don't.
I don't think I can claim either one of
them,
but obsessive struggle.
I think I am.
The first time I said it,
I think was just.
Then I don't believe I've said that
before,
but the idea is
someone at it throwing someone at a
swing and careful about how we express
our opinion about this amy schumer thing
without being completely serious.
Oh yeah.
It's another podcast.
I'm too drunk to defend my.
I don't want to jeopardize
the only like you live here.
I don't live around comedy.
You have more knowledge.
I would defend amy schumer,
but with blanks because I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't know either,
but I do know the w.
What's been proven is that the real
agregious ones that people believe are
an issue were written by other people
written by writers.
That's a.
That's why I was going to use schumer
who I know nothing about other than I
laughed at or special,
but there were times where bill maher
did shit where,
yo,
that's fucking mine because I'm a.
Yeah,
I don't think it's not a pedestrian
fucking comic and I would blame the
writers,
but I don't care because they can write
other shit.
Well,
there was a time where they kicked
writers of the back of the comedy store
because,
uh,
they were writing for a sketch show.
They were going on stage,
these comics going onstage and coming up
with these funny premises that would
wind up on these television sketch
shows,
it wanting to be acted out in a sketch.
And the people that were the writers of
the sketch show would go to the comedy
store and sit in the back room and they
got kicked out.
Wow.
Yeah.
And they got kicked out because they
were,
you know,
this was in the nineties,
ish.
You could get away with doing that kind
of shit.
You know what?
It's not.
It's like to put it all on her
shoulders.
His work.
It's weird.
It's like,
who the fuck knows who's writing those
sketches?
You know,
who knows what's writing those things.
The point is,
if she's already said it,
then it should be done.
If she said it publicly,
if you're in the back of the comedy
store,
when someone's working out some shit.
I've had several people do shit that I
already put out on dvd.
One of them became famous because of one
of a kevin booths,
yeah,
word of mouth,
but,
and he's admitted to me that he stole
that bit and that's what made it.
But I,
I stopped doing that because I put it on
a dvd and he's a nice guy.
He's got some problems,
but I don't give a fuck.
I got real problems in life.
It's just become.
It's like,
it's not like saying like this.
Someone comes up with somebody else's
idea.
they could never come up with their own
because you still can,
but
you're way better off just trying to
come up with all your own ideas.
If you came out with a story about a
euthanizing your own mother or attending
that euthanization like yerba.
I already put it out.
I don't give a fuck.
Well,
the only way someone would ever be able
to get away with it is if it was their
experience and they acknowledged that
they had heard of your experience as
well.
Like if someone becAme famous because of
that and
you're going.
But if some open mic or tried to do it,
who are going to be fucking called out
eventually fuck you.
I don't care.
I'm my life moves on.
I have real problems in my life.
But let me ask you this because that's
an intensely personal thing.
If a,
an open mic or say really did have an
experience where his mother
wanted him to help her commit suicide
and he went through with it and she died
and he decided to do a bit about it.
But acknowledging that he had seen your
bit as well,
like not not going through with it.
yeah.
Yeah.
It wasn't acknowledged me at all.
Well I think you should.
If someone stole that blatantly from me,
that's a different story.
But eliminate fuck because I have real
problem.
But to eliminate doubt.
Like if a guy only has on stage an hour,
right?
There's,
you don't want anybody in a state of
confusion going,
doug stanhope just joke about,
you know,
putting his mother to death.
You have to address that because that's
a big joke that you have.
Like it's like it's,
it's really like well respected and
enjoyed.
Joke,
so if someone was a doug stanhope fan
and they came to see this new dude and
this new dude really did have to help
his mom killed herself.
Right.
And,
and he said,
well,
I just have to say before I talked to
this,
I've talked about this,
like one of my favorite comedians,
doug stan hope or a guy I think is
fairly mediocre but extremely exciting.
Like whatever description he has for
you,
he should have to admit I'm a doug stand
hold fan.
I've listened to his comedy.
I think he's great and I,
I,
I couldn't believe this was happening to
me as well.
Like then he's talking about his own
life experience.
Like you can't eliminate a person's life
experience from the right,
but I think you like to make it easier
for everybody listening.
They should probably knowledge.
Like if someone did have to help their
mom committed suicide,
they should have to say in some sort of
a way if they shouldn't have to,
but it would be smart to say I've done
that.
Where I go is like so and so said.
Yeah,
but this happened to me.
Yeah.
Know it's good.
A question with a question would be like
going back to something jo said earlier,
which was,
what if that person is chris rock who's
like so much bigger and nobody knows who
the fuck you are?
Then you as joe rogan to step in and go,
I'm sorry carlos,
but are we already did that
and then you crush.
There's not a whole lot of guys that are
little spot where his career,
and I don't know if it's because you
deflated his ego so much or his
confidence or the people spoke out,
but after that incident he disappeared.
He went down to my level where if we're
doing a wednesday at the cleveland
improv one show only,
he's doing a thursday or vice versa,
but honestly that is not a bad thing.
Like what his life is is really good.
If he's headlined in these really nice
clubs all over the country,
he's not like in a bad place.
You know what happened?
There was all judgment aside.
What a.
There was like a blip in the matrix.
There was a problem with the,
the the operating system.
There was a reaL issue with how things
were going and guys like all of us,
anybody that was watching it was going,
well,
people are being being fucking
victimized here.
Like we had a real problem here,
like someone's taken.
It wasn't even taken from me.
he wasn't taken from you,
but it was some weird parasitic
situation that had been accepted into
the community because of sort of,
I don't like the term reverse racism,
but there's some,
some weird thing about choosing to like
pretend that some guys mexican is
because you think there's a market for
mexicans and this guy goes in there and
start stealing people's bits and
everybody accepts everything and then
the artists are sitting back,
sitting back on,
what the fuck are you doing?
Like you guys have found some weird
vein,
some weird river of revenue and the
attention,
and in this river of revenue and
you have to have a specific sort of
stereotypical ethnicity.
Uh,
so let's change your layout.
You know,
but that's exactly where you should not
give a fuck because those are not the
people you want to talk to.
The the whole idea that,
well,
oh,
he only likes them.
That's why I always hate the audience
instead of the artists.
If you can fucking have you,
if you're going to be a televangelist
and make a lot of people clap.
Yeah.
I'm going to hate you,
but I,
I can't hate you too much because you
got just like we have,
we have a cult.
You have a culture.
I have a cult are called commingle,
but we're fucking leaders of a cult.
So how dare you doug?
Stand home.
Prevailed.
The game.
Fucking tee shirts for your cold.
Cool t shirts.
Okay.
This caveman coffee.
This is tate fletcher.
Shirt point is people want to be led and
you get upset when their lead poorly by
some.
He's not even mexican.
Well,
they don't give a fuck.
That's not the.
It's the body issue.
The problem.
No.
People didn't feel like they could go on
stage in front of him if they weren't
famous because he would do their stuff
on comedy central and then this stuff
would no longer be their stuff because
if a guy's,
you know,
lupe fiasco and he's going up fucking
thursday night at the comedy store.
Dad,
I'm tired.
I've been in the loop for awhile,
but there's a million channels between
the internet and tv and everything so I
could actually steal people's material
and they would never know because
it's such a broad spectrum.
Not ever.
Not for channels.
Like when we were kids and oh,
he said that on Johnny Carson last
night.
You could steal material a
fucking fitzsimmons fitzsimmons had a
bit on one of his cds.
That was one of my bits.
I know we didn't steal it and then I had
one a bit silly and I called him up and
I go,
you know what,
you one of my bits and bits,
anything I don't give a fuck.
well fitzsimmons,
like he's a guy,
like if somehow or another you guys
tread on the same territory.
It's not by accident.
I mean,
it's not on purpose,
it's definitely a,
it's definitely a case of parallel
thinking,
but you would always know that if you
know fitzsimmons,
like if you felt very comfortable in
doing that bit.
Even after I heard fitzsimmons do it on
a cd
because I know he knows I didn't steal
it.
So of course.
Yeah.
I thought of this.
I know you.
Comedy is used to be a very small
community.
Maybe it's bigger when you live in la.
Well he,
it is the gut with the guy like
fitzsimmons with fitzsimmons.
It's a real small community because
he'll,
he'll be 100 percent real with you.
You know,
if you've talked to him about fucking
fitzsimmons yeah,
he's not.
This is like,
he doesn't,
he's not.
It's not possible for him to be a thief.
It'd be like breathing underwater.
Like he's never going to be a thief.
Bill burger.
I was hundred percent same.
One of the things we filmed for the bbc,
I'm like,
I have,
this is just a riffing topical thing and
I called him up.
I go,
did you do that?
I Swear I heard this on your podcast and
he goes,
I don't remember saying that.
I go,
are you sure?
Because I'm about to do this thing for
the bbc.
Riffing on concussions are surprised and
I still swear he did it,
but he doesn't know.
He goes,
nah,
I don't remember saying that.
Go ahead do it,
but thanks.
Good.
Heads up.
So do you think you heard it from him or
do you think you also thought of it?
No,
I think I heard it from him and I
checked with him and he swears he never
said it.
So maybe he's just remember.
No one talks more than him if you think
about it,
because he's the only one talking on
most of his podcasts.
I know you don't.
I don't remember my podcast after he
brings his wife and,
and they have a little chit chat or it's
him by himself.
I got to go.
Did I ruin it with my bill burr
impression?
I thought I did a great bill burr and
suddenly goes,
stopped doing that.
One person tweeted,
stop thinking.
You sound like bill burr one press got
my head ruins the whole part.
Cocksucker burst the most.
FuckIng cocksuckers bears the most
amazing podcast to me because it's just,
yeah,
it's just him and he will go like if
you.
If you done a podcast with him before
one time and it just wind tomorrow
morning,
we just got to wind them up.
Burger is
one of those guys,
he'll like change subjects like in the
middle of talking and they'll turn
another corner and take you down a road
and other rant and it turned another
corner taken out of the other way.
You just got to like,
he joined the ride like with such kid
gloves.
I was so fucked up wearing a leisure
suit.
You insisted on me driving with the top
down.
I had just done four hours of blow with
the musical artists named marilyn.
How dare you,
how dare you fucking just oLive oil.
And
it was a good hollywood
moment.
One of the guys that I most look forward
to watching right now,
like if I was a standup comedy fan,
if I'd never done standup before and I
was like,
what do I like?
I w I would go see her every chance.
I could.
Vre and joey diaz.
If you could just give me bert and joey
diaz at the same comedy club every
weekend.
You could live in bisbee,
Arizona.
Just have bird and joey diaz.
Every weekend
I would take joey over burr only because
I like to see the chance of a flame out.
The difference between driving and go
into tone,
apos speed way where everyone has a
fucking vega with a cessna engine jacked
up into it and they hope it'll work.
Did you ever see that video of that guy
was his tony stewart,
the guy that killed that guy on the
racetrack?
Yeah.
Some guy got out of his car.
Tony stewart hit him with his car.
It's so crazy to watch,
but I remember thinking like that guy in
nascar,
like that's nascar,
that tony's tour guy.
That guy drives on the dirt too,
like you drive on the dirt and like a
dune buggy and the people he drives
with,
they get mad.
They get out of their fucking car and
you run them over like what?
What they get out of their fucking car.
Could you imagine someone in nascar got
out of their fucking car?
How fast those guys going?
I have no idea.
Injured 200 miles an hour.
But that's how I.
Same thing,
right?
Yeah.
Kind of the same thing,
but it's the idea that you'd get her
standing in the way of a car.
That was bizarre.
The guy got out and stood there I think
because the tony stewart guy's car hit
his car and so he got out.
Oh jesus.
Jamie,
why don't you make us watch that dude
cut tumbled under that car.
Oh god.
That's so awful there for them.
That's so awful.
So he did that.
Oh yeah,
he's dead.
That guy's dead.
And his whole family was upset and they
blamed,
really upset because he was killed.
They dreamed it blamed on the driver.
I don't know enough about driving,
you know?
I don't know enough about driving to
determine whether or not
he can drive.
I'm fine.
I know I know enough about
lawyers.
Right,
but how does one make the distinction
whether or not he's at fault?
That's a.
That's a tricky distinction,
right?
I mean that guy just standing out there
in the middle of the track.
That's insane.
Watching footbaLl yesterday where we're
watching fucking helmet to helmet
contact,
that's.
That's assault and battery,
like intent to fuck.
That's attempted murder.
Basically your maiming people in a way.
Oh,
you're smashing people.
If I,
if I headbutted some dude in a bar,
could could I get a 15 yard penalty and
that's it,
but here's the question,
can you totally 100 percent be
responsible for head on head collisions
if you didn't intend them to be a head
on head collision and you're running
full clip towards some guy who's trying
to not have you tackle him like some
crazy shit happens,
right?
Like you have to take that into
consideration funnel.
What would it not completely go to the
criminal element where you go,
if it was against the law,
if it was against the rules and it was a
hockey brush,
shira thing where you got fucking wacky
with a stick and the guy did time
horrific.
That was horrific.
See hockey's a problem.
and here's one of the problems with
hockey.
It's a,
it's awesome.
That's one problem.
And one of the reasons why it's awesome
as they let them fight.
Oh no,
it's awesome because of hd.
Now when you have 60 inches high
definition,
so you can watch this fucking sport and
yeah,
love it.
Well,
I love hockey too,
for the same reason.
I love music.
So I have zero fucking talent.
I can't even skate.
If I got on skates,
I'll fall flat on my ass.
I'm just retarded.
we,
we did play basketball at a,
a whorehouse once and yeah,
the storm.
My basketball is not good.
Yeah.
Mio rogan.
Skating's worse.
Joe rogan is as talented as me shooting
horse.
I,
um,
I know a few.
Can I drop dennis hoff's name because he
doesn't get enough publicity on his own.
Um,
before we get out of here and doug,
stan,
hope I want to just tell you I'm leaving
now.
You just,
you finish up.
I'm going,
I just want to tell you I love what
you're doing and I love listening to
your podcast.
I love hearing about your antics down
there and bisbee and I wish you would
just run for mayor of bisbee and take
over and then we buy a comedy club and
we,
uh,
we just fucking,
you know,
we get the bar and free because those
people who can't pay any money to get
angry.
I didn't want a comedy club in my house.
that's right.
That's what I hear.
That's gonna work.
It's gonna work.
It's already working.
Correct.
Just for common,
especially at your house,
right?
Yes.
and uh,
except for the lighting.
Uh,
shut up.
Was it,
was it bright?
It never gets it with walls are painted.
You guys play this sentence?
No,
no.
I was,
I took,
I add an hour's worth of shit that
either I hadn't done on tape or get cut
out of other specials to make it an hour
and I got it while we're filming here.
Anyway,
we have a crew that's film one right in
the house at the funhouse going put 35
people tightly packed
and it fucking killed except when you
see the footage.
It was too brightly lit and that you
could do the reverse sweatshirts on the
internet.
Do you could use a negative filter,
so filter that makes it look like more
gloomy.
like maybe I
should try to make it gloomy.
Don't worry.
He'll be fake.
You can do it.
One is the audience was great and the
audience are my friends and they'll
laugh all the time and I can film comics
I like rather than say,
hey,
go bananas,
will you book my friend?
Hey,
let's fIlm it right here.
Am I my friends?
I can pack my own house every fucking
weekend and film dvds.
I think you should do a show with all
candle light.
Just a small candle light.
I had those fake little channels,
but someone overload the mother fucker.
Your host was badly wire.
Badly wired.
Yes.
I wasn't engaged in that job.
so listen,
I can understand the,
you know,
dealing with the unexpected.
You had to work with them.
I know what you're saying.
And electricity and weird,
badly wired houses.
Um,
we've got a great partnership though.
No,
you guys are an interesting group.
Really.
Are two of you together seem to work
well.
drove me out.
Why is that not a fucking thing?
There's two things.
A bali,
I go on gun.
Three things.
One,
I can't find a pack of cigarettes.
Oh,
he gave you fucking 400 cigarettes.
He did.
Alright.
Jesus christ,
he's got a carton in there.
Good.
He's been fucking someone in Mexico.
He won't talk about it.
So he keeps talking.
He keeps coming back from Mexico every
two weeks.
Listen,
this is duty free.
Is this a family friendly podcast or
something?
Not Anymore.
A fuck.
Now I can't remember the goddamn cast.
Swap,
cast,
swap,
cast.
I can't do it here because you do this
live.
When we do podcasts,
a lot of people are drinking and they
say shit.
They go,
oh,
fuck did.
I mentioned his name.
So we edit everything,
but if there's two comedians that both
have podcasts doing a podcast together,
it should be a swap cast where you both
put it out.
Two birds.
One stone.
Yeah.
That's a good move.
Yeah,
and I've been pitching this since I've
been doing it.
Well,
you could take this one if you want.
there's probably some content going.
Oh,
stan hope already did it.
No,
I'm saying you should steal that idea.
Well,
I think that a can't do it with you.
Whoa,
whoa.
We definitely could do it with me.
You could definitely take.
We'll give you a copy of it.
I think that,
uh,
I think regardless of how many people
are listening,
whether it's 10 or a million or 10
million,
who gives a shit,
it should.
Everybody was just sort of like
distributed,
you know,
the whole.
The beautiful thing about podcasts is
that everybody can get them for four
days and it doesn't,
it doesn't hurt me to give you the copy
of our show.
and you know,
it shouldn't hurt you.
It's not,
it's all I want.
I want people to listen to your show
because I listened to it.
Like there's plenty of that creeped me
out whether I listened that you had the
time to listen to a podcast that degas
shit out,
man.
I got time.
I just don't waste it.
I get sHit done.
I know that.
I realized if I didn't drink,
I'd have eight more hours in every day.
We have sat in the fun house in bisbee
and look at god and like look to joe
rogan's activity on a spreadsheet and
try to work out when it is your
sleeping.
You know,
we're like high on a minute.
He's doing this,
this and this happened.
But even if you did,
I'm telling you,
it's just seems way more impressive than
it is.
It's not that impressive.
Because like most days,
like jamie and I do a podcast,
we worked for three hours maximum.
He works more than me.
He worked four and a half and we're
done.
And we do that like three days a week.
And that's it.
So there's a podcast right?
And Then,
then there's the,
the fake research that goes into finding
podcast guests,
which is just really just shit I'm
interested in.
I never think like,
wow,
I've got to fuck.
He's good.
No.
Who's that?
Who is this?
He's a character.
you're going to come in and a wig?
No,
we're cool.
If you had rat radley balko on yet.
Uh,
andy kaufman,
he used to work for a police and now
he's huffington post.
he's the guy that gets,
he's an investigative journalist that
does all the cops that stopped people
and bust them and steal their shit.
He wrote,
he wrote a book last year.
The rise of the warrior cop.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
No,
I have that book,
man.
Right?
He's fucking brilliant.
Yeah.
I have that book.
That's when I was books that I started
and then I just got distracted and never
finished it.
Get a myth.
Fucking unbelievable.
It's not even their fault.
That's the same thing we were talking
about earlier.
And I really believe in my office,
no motivated algae about a technology
progresses and as long as people stay
alive and you can feed them,
there is no famine,
there's no diseases.
Technology's going to continue to
progress.
I think that like the same thing happens
With like enforcing the law,
whether it comes
or trying to make money or whatever it
is that people pursue.
They tried to improve upon whatever
results they've had the previous
trimester,
semester,
year,
quarter,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's just an inherent part of being a
person.
So if it's about busting people,
you want a bus more fudging people.
It's just,
it's a game,
it becomes an busting.
You becomes a game and as soon as it
like a wind loss,
then you're getting people that are
addicted to like winning in football or
baseball or fucking whatever else it is.
Or dancing with the stars.
When is dancing?
Why?
That's a competition.
For years people have not been judged
for their next.
No one would watch it and it's no shit.
No one would watch it until it became a
competition.
It should be.
That's right.
As one of your pins.
Yeah.
Everything's one of our bits.
I know the bots,
the bots being uh,
when we've been doing it this long,
you realize you're just doing an old
bit.
Yeah.
In a way.
I mean how many coffees something you
thought of before and now you're saying
it different on a podcast in a
conversational way and then you go,
yeah.
And even in the most original thought,
there's still like a rhythm to it,
right?
There's still that rhythm of three that
we all follow.
If for some reason works well because
you're deaf now I don't know if it's
genetics or real,
whatever it is,
whatever it is.
I mean,
of course I know gen x are real,
but I don't know.
It's like expressing ideas through jokes
from one parent to child.
I don't knoW if that's possible,
but people believe it is that they
believe that it's possible that memes
and even racism might be passed from.
And I don'T mean memes like internet
means,
but like ideas like ideas might be able
to be passed,
like the reaction and contemplation and
solution of an idea might be passed from
parent to child where the child almost
immediately goes to the same resolution
or solution that the parent did almost
instinctively.
Like they have it programmed their
genome,
but it's really controversial.
You've seen that footage of the monkeys
with assault and.
Yeah,
that's exactly what that is,
is it is.
Yeah.
And a lot of ways they've done it with
mice where they figured out a way to
have a citrus smell and they would spray
the citrus smell,
it would smell it and they would shock
their feet.
and the mice offspring who did not
experience the same experiment still,
when they would blast the citrus smell,
they would have some sort of a,
um,
a reaction,
like a stress reaction to like something
coming at them.
The same video last night.
oh,
who is the original?
How dare you?
It's not me.
It's definitely not me.
I don't know who I got it from.
It's been,
it probably was like serious originally.
I was going to say stern,
but uh,
how dare you.
Was it a stern originated everything?
Hey now or that was that the guy from
Larry Sanders.
Those sandals.
Yeah,
that guy was crazy.
He is awesome.
He had a go.
I'm traveling,
so
I have to drive really fast.
Got
brian hannigan.
Tell the people how to follow you on the
twitter,
the instagram.
Brian hannigan.
I'm not done.
Doug.
Stan hope you relaxed.
We're not at a time.
There was no network here.
There's no one to yell at you about
stiff verse at heart.
I can't hear you.
What was that?
And again,
I am brian hennigan.
I missed her hennigan on twitter and
instagram.
And you have a book coming out on
understand.
I have a novel that I just know it's a
republication of uh,
my first novel that was published in the
uk a while ago and it got great reviews
and it was never published in the u.
S beautiful.
He,
uh,
it's fiction.
I never read fiction and I tried to read
his book,
but I know him.
So I'm listening to the first 30,
40 pages in his voice and then then I
got past that and it was funny as shit.
So I went to his apartment.
I was staying there when he was away and
I just left it with the last three pages
unread.
Like I read the whole book and became so
disinterested in three pages.
I left it open like that.
He didn't notice.
That'S true.
That's probably digging up.
Mother are joe rogan is a name checked
in as a on amazon.
You can preorder that and there'll be
avaIlable in the uk.
douglas boy.
Will there be more visits to los
angeles?
Unfortunately,
yes.
Why don't you just try to be one of
those intercontinental motherfuckers.
Get yourself a fat spread out here and
use some of that standup comedy loot to
make your life.
we were waiting for someone to move out
of our fucking rent control apartment
building.
That's all well and good.
BuT I think in the interest of,
in the,
in the interest of a god,
I would have,
if I could have stood this whole time,
I'm a altruism,
you know,
help for like the young comics maybe
perhaps that rent controlled apartment
could be some sort of a local dive like
shaq place where people can go and stay
for the comics to us are guys who've
only been doing it for 15 years.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what I'm talking about.
And you can get like a nice place over
sarah silverman lives,
but you get a view.
Do parks your car for you to come on.
Doug stanhope.
Alright,
we're gonna.
Wrap this up,
jamie.
Thank you America.
We appreciate everything about you.
Sorry I was really fucked up for the
lot.